bonjour à tous La séance est ouverte
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
Gouvernement la première d'entre elles
va être posée par le président Marc
Angeli pour le groupe horizon
merci madame la Présidente
madame la Première ministre la Nouvelle
Vague est là et l'année passée
le nouveau cas de covid-19 cette semaine
l'épidémie de bronchiolite qui serait
répand sur tout le territoire et le
démarrage précoce de celle de grippe les
indicateurs sanitaires sont au rouge
les passages aux urgences c'est
hospitalisations pour broncholite
atteignent ainsi un niveau inédit depuis
10 ans ce qui suscite l'inquiétude
légitime de nombreux parents
ces chiffres laissent entrevoir une
hausse des hospitalisations pendant la
période de Noël qui arrive à grands pas
déjà particulièrement tendu pour nos
services de soins nous vivons en
parallèle une situation dramatique sur
notre territoire des services d'urgence
qui ferment des départs à la retraite
des postes vacants des milliers de
Français n'arrivent plus à voir accès à
des soins près de chez eux entretenant
une spirale de saturation dont nous
peinons à sortir
ce n'est pas la première période de
forte tension en juillet dernier
Monsieur le Ministre de la Santé avait
pris le sujet à bras le corps en
déclinant de nombreuses mesures pour
répondre à la saturation de nos services
d'urgence face à la crise pédiatrique
dont nous parlions dans cette hémicycle
il y a encore quelques semaines
certaines de ces mesures ont été
reprises en plus du déblocage d'une
enveloppe dédiée
le gouvernement apparaît annoncé la
semaine passée l'investissement de plus
de 500 millions d'euros supplémentaires
afin de permettre une prise en charge
optimale des malades dès cette année
dans les établissements de santé nous
saluons ce choix marqueur d'un
engagement continu pour l'hôpital madame
la Première ministre face à cette
nouvelle donne critique pourriez-vous
indiquer à la représentation nationale
quelles sont les mesures que le
Gouvernement compte mettre en oeuvre
pour faire face à cette situation et
permettre à nos concitoyens de passer
leur fête de fin d'année le plus
sereinement possible je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Madame la première ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
Président Laurent Marc Angeli vous avez
raison de le dire et de tirer la
sonnette d'alarme car aujourd'hui
l'épidémie de covid repart avec plus de
40 000 cas détectés par jour une
progression de près de 10% des espèces
hospitalisations sur une semaine une
hausse de 22% des hospitalisations soins
critiques et 400 décès du covid la
semaine passée
cette nouvelle cette nouvelle vague nous
le rappelle le virus n'a pas disparu
l'épidémie frappe encore tue encore
et si je fais ce rappel aujourd'hui
c'est parce que notre hôpital va encore
faire face à une pression supplémentaire
car elle a reprise du covid s'ajoute une
épidémie de bronchiolite la plus élevée
des dix dernières années qui provoquent
des tensions notamment sur nos services
pédiatriques s'ajoutent également une
épidémie de grippe saisonnière
particulièrement virulent cette année
avec 5 régions en phase préépidémique et
des premiers effets sur notre hôpital
des mesures ont été prises notamment le
déclenche déclenchement du plan Orsan
pour mobiliser l'ensemble des personnels
et accroître les capacités de prise en
charge ainsi que la mobilisation par les
ARS et les préfets pour coordonner
l'ensemble des acteurs de terrain
face à cette situation je veux une
nouvelle fois rendre hommage au travail
exceptionnel de nos soignants
il se battent pour les malades il se
battent contre l'épidémie leur
engagement est exceptionnel alors notre
devoir c'est de les aider pas de prendre
des mesures purement idéologiques qui
rendraient leur mission plus difficile
encore
aider nos soignants c'est être vigilant
ensemble et je lance un appel solennel
respectons les gestes barrières portons
le masque dès que nous sommes avec des
personnes fragiles ou dans des zones de
promiscuité comme les transports en
commun ce sont des petits gestes qui
sauvent des vies nous le savons ils sont
décisifs pour faire reculer l'épidémie
les Français ont toujours répondu à
l'appel de la responsabilité je n'ai
aucun doute qu'il le feront de nouveau
et dès nos soignants ensuite c'est la
vaccination la vaccination contre la
grippe qui peut être déterminante et qui
est malheureusement très basse cette
année et la vaccination contre le covid
dont nous font avec certitude qu'elle
sauve des vies depuis octobre une
campagne de vaccination de rappel de
vaccins a été lancé pour les personnes
de plus de 60 ans les personnes fragiles
et bien sûr les soignants seuls 10% de
la population cible ont effectué leur
rappel c'est bien trop peu alors je le
redis au Français concernés
vaccinez-vous cela vous protège cela
protège notre hôpital enfin mesdames et
messieurs les députés aider nos
soignants c'est défendre la science
défendre notre système de santé et ne
pas prendre des décisions qui les
mettraient en danger avec la majorité
j'assume de défendre notre système de
soins j'assume de refuser de faire
passer les manœuvres politiques avant la
science j'assume de ne pas soutenir des
mesures purement démagogiques que
l'écrasante majorité des soignants nous
demandent de rejeter
j'ai entendu ces derniers jours des
propos terrifiants sur les vaccins
certains confine à l'obscurantisme et je
ne pensais pas dans cette émission dans
le pays de pasteur dire que l'on a
confiance dans la parole de nos
scientifiques et dans l'efficacité de
nos vaccins prêterait à des débats aussi
vifs mais vos hurlements ne nous feront
pas reculer nous assumons nous ferons
toujours le choix de la responsabilité
toujours le choix de la science nous
serons toujours aux côtés des soignants
et des malades je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Michel Martinez
pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de
l'économie monsieur le ministre les
intoxications à monoxyde de carbone sont
Lolo chaque période hivernale mais cette
année en raison de la hausse du prix de
l'énergie une augmentation de ces
accidents était la fortement ta craindre
les Français sont plongés dans la
précarité énergétique la crainte de
facture impayées et les coupures
d'électricité qui semble inéluctables
les poux à avoir recours à des moyens de
chauffage insalubre voire complètement
inadapté quitte à mettre leur vie en
danger qui aurait pu imaginer que la
France finirait dans cet état notre pays
qui pendant des décennies pouvait être
fier de son indépendance en termes
d'énergie se retrouve maintenant dans
une situation accablante et importe plus
d'électricité qui n'en exportent
prouvant une fois de plus la fin de
notre souveraineté énergétique
certes sous la pression du RN vous avez
enfin accordé une modeste aux familles
qui se chauffent au fur et au bois mais
c'est encore insuffisant les français
payent le prêt de votre incompétence
depuis François Hollande vous échangez
des voix des écologistes contre une
politique énergétique suicidaire abandon
du nucléaire péréquation européenne du
prix de l'énergie qui nous pousse à
sponsoriser la politique énergétique de
l'Allemagne avant ta perte notre énergie
nucléaire décarbonée depuis des mois
vous promettez une réforme du prix
d'électricité c'est un échec ce qui
prouve que nous avons raison vous êtes
incapable de défendre les Français alors
qu'il suffit de sortir du marché
européen comme le propose Marine Le Pen
monsieur le ministre que compte faire le
gouvernement pour que compte faire le
gouvernement pour redonner à la France
l'indépendance énergétique qui permettra
à ses citoyens de se chauffer décemment
pouvez-vous garantir que les Français ne
subiront pas de coupure d'électricité
cet hiver je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Agnès panière une
ministre de la transition énergétique
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Martinez merci de me donner l'occasion
d'éclairer notre politique énergétique
parce que contrairement à ce que vous
indiquez cette politique énergétique
elle a déjà fait ses preuves pour
protéger les Français protéger les
Français c'est être le pays qui amortit
le plus le coût de l'augmentation de
l'énergie sur le portefeuille des
Français avec le bouclier électricité
avec le bouclier gaz avec l'amortisseur
électrique pour les entreprises avec les
dispositions prises au niveau du
ministère de l'Économie pour accompagner
les entreprises et donc sécuriser les
emplois pour cette raison nous sommes le
pays où le niveau d'inflation est le
plus faible d'Europe alors certes ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas une bonne
nouvelle d'avoir de l'inflation mais
reconnaissons aujourd'hui que ce
gouvernement a pris les mesures pour
protéger les Français c'est également un
gouvernement qui a pris toutes les
mesures pour construire notre
indépendance énergétique car
contrairement à ce que vous dites madame
Martinez jamais la France n'a été
indépendante énergétiquement le
nucléaire c'est 20% de notre énergie
totale deux tiers de notre énergie est
importé et aujourd'hui vous êtes le
groupe qui empêchait la France de
déployer des énergies renouvelables en
vous mettant dans une opposition stérile
et déconnectée au projet que nous
portons d'accélération des énergies
renouvelables alors reconnaissez que le
silence s'il vous plaît
pratique aujourd'hui nous sommes au
travail sur la sobriété sur l'efficacité
énergétique sur l'accélération des
déploiements des énergies renouvelables
et sur la relance du programme nucléaire
nous avons un programme nous protégeons
les Français et ils nous font confiance
je vous remercie madame Martinez
pouvez-vous nous garantir que les
Français ne subiront pas de coupure
d'électricité cet hiver merci
la parole est à Monsieur Frédéric
maillot pour le groupe gauche-démocrate
et républicaine madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse au ministre du
Logement le bouclier est tarifaire a été
mis en place pour les Français dont le
logement sont dotés d'un compteur
individuel ce dispositif qui voit leur
facture exploser les commerçants et les
boulangers dont certains ferment déjà et
les bouchers qui manifestent aujourd'hui
devant les palais Bourbon mais ce ne
sont pas les seuls ce bouclier tarifaire
laisse aussi de côté bon nombre de nos
concitoyens à commencer par les
habitants de La Réunion ou ce bouclier
ne s'applique pas en France continentale
alors que l'hiver débute les habitants
de 17 millions de logements en
copropriété dont 5 millions en logements
sociaux sont déjà étranglés
financièrement la faute aux régulations
de charges collectives notamment de
chauffage en augmentation de 150 à 200%
qui ne sont pas couverts par le bouclier
tarifaire dans certains cas c'est
l'équivalent d'un mois de ressources qui
doit être réglé avant les impossible
impossible pour un retraité qui perçoit
une pension de 800 euros ou pour un
foyer qui vit avec un SMIC c'est
impossible et insupportable nous
demandons donc l'égalité pour tous
l'égalité entre ce qui vivent dans un
logement individuel et ceux qui vivent
dans un logement collectif l'égalité
entre l'hexagone et l'outre-mer l'USH et
le mouvement Hlm on fait différentes
propositions il demande dans l'immédiat
le prolongement et l'élargissement du
bouclier tarifaire et du chèque énergie
l'application d'un taux de TVA de 5,5%
sur le gaz et l'électricité et
l'abondement de fonds de solidarité pour
le logement par l'État et les
énergéticiens monsieur le ministre se
loger manger vivre la question est
insupportable il y a urgence absolue les
solutions sont sur les tables que
comptez-vous faire pour tout tous les
exclus du bouclier tarifaire
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
maillot
vous évoquez
le chauffage
collectif ce qui nécessite pour moi de
préciser deux choses simples vous avez
raison sur le fait qu'il y a un
dispositif pour tous les particuliers
qui est le bouclier tarifaire et que
nous avions un trou dans la raquette sur
le bouclier collectif pour le chauffage
au gaz qui a été réparé par le décret du
9 avril qui a été étendu jusqu'au 31
décembre le sujet qui reste c'est le
chauffage collectif à l'électricité pour
lequel c'est une question de jours avant
que le décret rétroactif
soit pris par ce gouvernement et
s'applique à compter du mois de juillet
ce qui veut dire que une partie des
avances de charge dont vous parlez
feront l'objet de régularisation moment
où ce bouclier s'appliquera de manière
rétroactive en appliquant le dispositif
du bouclier tarifaire à toutes ces
situations vous avez raison d'évoquer
l'usage vous avez raison d'évoquer les
discussions que nous avons parce que
c'est avec les bailleurs sociaux
notamment même s'il y a des chauffages
collectifs qui sont parfois dans des
résidences privées qui ne sont pas
couvertes par le mouvement social c'est
avec eux que nous avons sur ce sujet le
deuxième c'est celui du chèque énergie
et du fait que dans un certain nombre de
cas on a des bénéficiaires de ce chèque
énergie qui ne l'utilisent pas et sur
lequel on a une simplification à opérer
notamment avec les opérateurs du
mouvement social au sens large ça aussi
c'est au cœur des discussions que nous
avons avec Emmanuel cosse et avec lui et
sache voilà les éléments que je peux
vous donner monsieur le député
je vous remercie monsieur maillot
merci de reconnaître que j'ai raison
mais cela n'apporte pas de réponse au
boulanger et au boucher qui ferme leur
boutique les uns après les autres et qui
est manifestent vent aujourd'hui devant
le Palais Bourbon c'est à ce eux aussi
qu'il faut donner raison monsieur le
Premier ministre
la parole
[Musique]
est à Monsieur le Ministre excusez-moi
je suis désolé vous aviez quelques
secondes allez-y
monsieur le député
monsieur le député merci de reconnaître
que la réponse que je vous ai faite vous
satisfait au moins sur un point puisque
vous ne me réinterrogez pas sur le
chauffage collectif mais que sur la
situation de ce qui est effectivement
ont des contrats à hauteur de 36 kg et
pour cela c'est l'amortisseur
électricité qui prend le relais et pour
lequel le dispositif a été présenté qui
nous permettra de prendre une partie du
cours
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
donc la parole est à Monsieur veau
jetable pour le comprenez ça
merci madame la Présidente la question
s'adresse également monsieur Christophe
bechut ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion du
territoire monsieur le ministre prenez
quelques instants pour imaginer la scène
vous rentrez chez vous ce soir vous
mettez la clé dans la serrure de votre
domicile et vous réalisez que celle-ci a
été modifiée rapidement vous devez vous
rendre à l'évidence quelqu'un a pris
possession de votre logement un
squatteur
face à ces situations nous avons agi en
renforçant la procédure d'expulsion
Express des squatteurs à travers la loi
ASAP en 2020 grâce à cette procédure
170 victimes de squatteurs ont déjà pu
récupérer leur domicile en quelques
jours seulement mais il nous faut aller
plus loin il n'est pas normal qu'un
propriétaire qui sort lui-même un
squatteur de sa propriété soit exposer à
des sanctions pénales trois fois plus
élevées que le squatteur lui-même
il nous faut agir également sur l'enfer
juridique et administratif que vivent
des victimes non pas de squatteur mais
de locataires indélicats qui ne payent
plus leur loyer depuis des années je
pense ainsi à Pierre et Maryse de
Marseille qui se retrouve à vivre
actuellement dans leur caravane car leur
appartement est occupé par une locataire
qui ne leur paye plus ses loyers depuis
deux ans ni eux ni nous ne pouvons
accepter que ces procédures puissent
s'étendre jusqu'à 5 ans
il faut donc agir à nouveau non pas pour
permettre à de riches Thénardier de
martyriser des malheureux Jean Valjean
comme on voudrait nous le faire croire
mais bien pour aider ces nombreux
Français petit propriétaire victimes
d'impayés et qui sont souvent poussés
eux vers la précarité par ce type
d'agissement
c'est pour cela que nous discuterons en
séance aujourd'hui la proposition de loi
de notre collègue Guillaume kasbien un
texte attendu par les Français et une
cause qui devrait espérons-le rassembler
la représentation nationale bien au-delà
de cette majorité aussi Monsieur le
Ministre pouvez-vous nous expliquer dans
quelle mesure cette proposition permet
d'améliorer le marché locatif en
protégeant toutes les victimes d'abus
qu'il soit de l'eau propriétaire ou
locataire de bonne foi mais en
difficulté
merci
la parole est à Monsieur Christophe
Béchu ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député
votre question est particulièrement
d'actualité puisque la proposition de
loi portée par le président kasbien a
commencé à être examiné hier va l'être à
nouveau ce soir
sécuriser les propriétaires c'est
s’assurer qu'on ne se retrouve pas avec
des demandes de garantie qui ne cessent
d'augmenter avec des refus de loués qui
viendraient tendre un peu plus le marché
locatif pour vous répondre de manière
extrêmement directe vous avez cité des
cas il y en a malheureusement trop qui
sont des cas qui frappent l'opinion
publique et qui montre que nous avons
aujourd'hui malgré les modifications
législatives un équilibre qui n'est pas
atteint entre le droit des propriétaires
et ce droit au logement qui conduit sous
couvert de squats à se retrouver dans
des situations où on inverse la charge
de la responsabilité sur des
propriétaires qui ne demandaient pas
tant
pour autant votre proposition de loi
calme mérite d'être large de ne pas
faire l'impasse sur des sujets qui sont
des sujets compliqués sur lesquels les
Français nous attendent va au-delà des
squats pour traiter la situation des
locataires et pour s'assurer que nous
n'avons pas des locataires qui sont de
mauvaise foi qui abuseraient aussi d'un
équilibre qui ne serait pas atteint le
point de vigilance du gouvernement c'est
de soutenir pleinement la nécessité
d'être ferme avec les squatteurs de
modifier de manière radicale les
équilibre qui existent mais dès qu'elles
demandent d'être capable de distinguer
les locataires qui sont de bonnes et de
mauvaise foi et il ne faudrait pas qu'à
l'occasion de la proposition de loi à
partir de motifs qui sont légitimes on
n'arrive pas à trouver un équilibre qui
est celui auquel le gouvernement est
attaché qui consiste réellement à
défendre les propriétaires mais pas
englober des gens qui seraient dans des
situations humaines complexes ou
douloureuses et qui ne doivent pas être
emportés sous couvert d'une vision de
mauvaise foi trop rapide
[Applaudissements]
la période de Noël approche combien
n'auront rien ou si peu à se mettre sous
le sapin je veux vous parler de la prime
de Noël seulement 2 millions de Français
la touchera elle ne sera pas versée à
ceux qui touchent une retraite de misère
aux jeunes sans ressources ni aux
personnes en handicap ce n'est pas
normal ce n'est pas juste je vous
demande donc de l'élargir à tous les
bénéficiaires des minima sociaux et il
faut la revaloriser elle ne l'a pas été
depuis 2007 avec l'inflation elle doit
passer à 200 euros cette prime c'est
l'urgence et qu'allez-vous faire pour le
long terme le grand plan de lutte contre
la pauvreté en 2019 repoussée puis
abandonné le chèque alimentaire repoussé
puis enterré le revenu universel
d'activité promesse du président il a
été patiemment balayé votre dispositif
de solidarité à la source pour lutter
contre le non recours aux prestations
social connaîtra-t-il le même sort vous
annoncez des premières expérimentations
en 2023 ou en sommes-nous faisons très
vite madame la Première ministre avant
que notre pays ne se déchire encore plus
il est temps d'agir enfin pour les
Français les plus pauvres
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
députés monsieur le président Bertrand
pencher
l'une des grandes batailles de mon
gouvernement vous le savez c'est
l'égalité des chances et la lutte contre
la pauvreté est au cœur de l'égalité des
chances
c'est pourquoi nous agissons de manière
résolue déterminée notamment grâce à la
stratégie pauvreté 2018-2022
cette stratégie ce sont des actions
directes concrètes pour permettre aux
familles précaires d'avoir un toit de se
soigner de garantir une alimentation
suffisante et équilibrée à leurs enfants
nous voulons agir directement sur la
pauvreté en répondant aux problèmes
quotidiens notre stratégie c'est aussi
une action pour l'égalité des chances
pour notre jeunesse je pense au plus de
100000 élèves qui bénéficient des repas
à la cantine à moins d'un euro à la
création des centres et maisons
participatif ou encore au déploiement
des accueils sociaux de proximité qui
couvrent désormais plus de 90% du
territoire
mesdames et messieurs les députés le
sujet de la pauvreté appelle à
l'humilité toujours mais nous avançons
en dépit de la crise sanitaire le taux
de pauvreté n'a pas augmenté au cours
des trois dernières années et il reste
un niveau bas en comparaison
internationale le nombre d'allocataires
du RSA diminue depuis 9 ans 2020 en juin
dernier il est repassé sous son niveau
de janvier 2017 mais aujourd'hui et
c'est le sens de votre question monsieur
le Président nous devons amplifier nos
efforts la stratégie pauvreté 2018-2022
arrive à son terme et nous avons initié
les travaux avec les collectivités et
avec les associations pour préparer la
suite cela se concrétisera par un pacte
des solidarités structurées autour de
quatre axes la lutte contre les
inégalités à la racine le retour à
l'activité clé d'une sortie durable de
la pauvreté le refus de se résigner à la
grande marginalité et la transition
écologique solidaire donc vous le voyez
nous préparons l'avenir mais il nous
faut aussi traiter l'urgence parce que
l'inflation appelle une réponse forte
une réponse rapide surtout pour les plus
fragiles et c'est pour cela que nous
avons décidé dès cet été de revaloriser
de manière anticipée les prestations
sociales à hauteur de 4 % elles seront
naturellement revalorisées à nouveau au
premier avril prochain à hauteur de
l'inflation c'est pour cela que nous
avons pris les mesures les plus
protectrices d'Europe pour limiter la
hausse des prix du gaz et de
l'électricité c'est pour cela que nous
avons revalorisé de 50% au 1er novembre
la location de soutien familial pour les
parents qui élèvent seuls leurs enfants
et c'est pour cela aussi que nous avons
mis en place une aide exceptionnelle de
solidarité qui a bénéficié à 11 millions
de personnes et le 15 décembre prochain
nous verserons de manière automatique la
prime de Noël à plus de 2,3 millions de
ménage notamment les bénéficiaires du
RSA ou de l'Allocation Spécifique de
Solidarité ça représente 500 cette prime
traduit l'engagement constant de mon
gouvernement à soutenir le pouvoir
d'achat des ménages et accompagner ceux
qui en ont le plus besoin nous ne
laisserons personne au bord du chemin je
vous remercie je vous remercie madame la
Première ministre
la parole est à monsieur le Président
Marley
madame la Première ministre
le premier quinquennat du président
Macron a été marqué par de nombreux
renoncements dans le domaine de notre
souveraineté industrielle Alstom Alcatel
Technip Dassault est aujourd'hui un de
nos derniers champions industriel
tricolore exerçant un leadership mondial
dans son domaine l'aviation de combat or
depuis plusieurs années le projet
d'avion de combat européen du futur le
Scaff fait l'objet d'un bras de fer
entre Français et Allemand sur la
maîtrise d'oeuvre du projet avec en
toile de fond la question de la maîtrise
du savoir-faire industriel ce projet a
été plusieurs fois reporté notamment
parce que le gouvernement allemand
faisait du partage de la technologie de
un préalable à toute discussion or dans
un contexte franco-allemand largement
dégradé je pense au désaccord sur la
gestion de la crise énergétique à
l'annulation du Conseil des ministres
franco-allemand ou à de nombreux projets
de coopération militaire déjà abandonnés
du futur ou le drone européen le
gouvernement allemand a communiqué de
manière unilatérale sur la conclusion
d'un accord accord que vous avez
vous-même confirmé madame la Première
ministre lors de votre déplacement
vendredi dernier à Berlin
or quelques heures après l'entreprise
Dassault a rappelé que rien n'était
signé madame le Premier ministre où en
est-on donc sur ce dossier un accord
a-t-il été trouvé pouvez-vous garantir
sur le nainement alors présentation
nationale que c'est bien d'assaut qui
sera maître d'oeuvre de l'avion de du
système de combat pouvez-vous assurer
que les droits de propriété
intellectuelle sur les brevets actifs
stratégiques de la Défense nationale ne
seront pas cédés et pouvez-vous nous
certifier que d'assuer la France
garderont toute leur liberté d'action
pour l'exportation de ces avions sans se
garantie ce serait une énième soumission
française face à l'Allemagne pour sauver
la Grande Illusion d'un couple franco
allemand sur le dos de Dassault et ce
serait inacceptable
je vous remercie la parole est à madame
la Première ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
président Olivier marlex
souveraineté stratégique française et
européenne et déterminante et nous la
défendons avec force alors vous
m'interrogez sur le projet de système de
combat aérien du futur le SCAP ce projet
ambitieux lancé en 2017 menée en
coopération avec l'Allemagne et
l'Espagne atteint aujourd'hui une étape
importante de son développement
tout d'abord sur la nature du projet
comme vous le savez le Scaff est un
système complet c'est un avion de combat
associé à des drones c'est un système
qui sera structurant pour nos forces
armées pour être demain en mesure d'agir
efficacement sur tout le spectre des
missions aériennes de combat y compris
la dissuasion le Scave c'est donc un
enjeu opérationnel conservé à horizon
2040 notre supériorité aérienne et notre
capacité d'action dans la troisième
dimension oui mesdames et messieurs la
France est engagée dans le Scaff parce
qu'elle y trouve son intérêt avec ses
partenaires allemands et espagnol c'est
une coopération majeure elle garantit
l'interopérabilité de nos forces elle
renforce la souveraineté européenne tout
en préservant nos intérêts stratégiques
industrielles et technologie oui
mesdames et messieurs les députés
l'appui du gouvernement est de nos
partenaires à ce projet est totale nos
trois pays ont récemment réaffirmé leur
détermination à aller de l'avant le
président de la République s'y est
personnellement investi c'est un grand
pas et dans le contexte international
actuel c'est un signal important de
l'excellente coopération entre nations
le chanceux chancelier Scholtz avec qui
j'ai pu m'entretenir vendredi dernier à
Berlin à lui-même marqué son attachement
au projet et sa confiance dans une
conclusion rapide l'impulsion et la
volonté politique sont là mais vous
m'interrogez monsieur le Président
Marleix plus spécifiquement sur les
enjeux industriels du SCAF avec le
ministre des Armées Sébastien Lecornu
nous disent nous y sommes évidemment
particulièrement attentifs aujourd'hui
nous nous engageons dans une nouvelle
phase du projet la réalisation du
démonstrateur qui précède les phases de
développement et de production après
plus d'un an de discussions sur ce
programme complexe les positions des
industriels convergent nous sommes bien
dans la période de finalisation des
contrats je vous l'ai dit nous nous
assurons de la cohérence de ce programme
avec nos intérêts stratégiques notre
capacité à exporter est un des critères
fondamentaux et il est connu de nos
partenaires nous ne transigerons pas la
soutenabilité financière est un prêt
requis là non plus nous ne transigerons
pas mesdames et messieurs les députés
nous construisons avec nos industriels
et avec nos partenaires un outil qui
fera référence et qui nous permettra de
conserver un avantage sur nos
compétiteurs un outil qui assure la
souveraineté industrielle et stratégique
de la France je remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame Brigitte
les eaux pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente
madame la ministre le Baudot ce jeudi
1er décembre marque la journée
internationale de lutte contre le sida
mais ce premier décembre 2022 ne
ressemble pas au précédent cette année
nous pouvons ici tous porter un message
d'espoir la France peut être le premier
pays à peut-être voir la fin de la
contamination auia OVH d'ici 2027 j'en
suis convaincu c'est notre législatif
notre législature qui va atteindre cet
objectif après 40 ans de drame et de vie
brisé
tous les spécialistes sont unanimes nous
en avons les moyens grâce au progrès
considérable des traitements et aux
prises en charge des patients mais nous
n'y arriverons pas sans prendre des
mesures fortes pour augmenter le nombre
de dépistages et en particulier chez les
jeunes les chiffres sont alarmants 13%
de nouveaux cas sont des jeunes de moins
de 25 ans près de 28% des séropositifs
sont diagnostiqués avec une affection
avancée la faute à la crise pas
seulement et en tout cas je ne le pense
pas depuis plusieurs années le sida ne
fait plus peur comme avant on l'entend
souvent dire on peut vivre avec ce n'est
pas si grave il existe des traitements
et bien soyons clairs le sida tue encore
et toujours chers collègues
ce combat est le combat de tous c'est
notre combat alors chacun d'entre nous
dans chacune de nos circonscriptions
passons ce message simple le dépistage
du VIH est gratuit et sans ordonnance
soutenons nos associations participation
participant à des actions de
sensibilisation parlons sans tabou dans
les écoles les collèges les lycées ce
combat nous le devons à tous ceux qui
souffrent et à tous ceux qui nous ont
quittés
Line Renaud l'a dit quelqu'un de
dépister c'est quelqu'un de soigner qui
ne transmet plus la maladie et c'est
vrai alors madame la ministre
qu'envisagez-vous pour améliorer les
taux de dépistage et sensibiler encore
et encore la population au risque de VIH
et MSI
la parole est à Madame Agnès Firmin le
Bodo ministre délégué chargé de
l'organisation territoriale et des
professions de santé madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée Brigitte isot
votre question madame la députée est
essentielle à l'avant de la journée
mondiale de lutte contre le sida et
alors que les données de santé publique
France montrent que le nombre de
personnes se découvrent séropositives
reste stable quel que soit la population
concernée et vous avez eu raison de dire
que oui le sida tue encore et toujours
le gouvernement entend approfondir ses
efforts pour améliorer la prévention le
dépistage et le traitement du VIH à
travers la mise en œuvre de les actions
de la nouvelle feuille de route 2021
2024 la généralisation depuis cette
année de l'accès aux dépistage
sérologique du VIH sans prescription
pris en charge à 100%. le renforcement
de notre stratégie globale de prévention
elle repose à la fois sur le préservatif
le dépistage du VIH et des autres
IST leur traitement le traitement le
traitement post-exposition et la
prophylaxie pré-exposition dite prep
depuis le 1er janvier 2021 un premier
pas a été franchi avec l'ouverture de la
primo prescription de la prep à tout
médecin afin de favoriser un recours à
ce dispositif
l'accessibilité du traitement
post-exposition a également été accéléré
avec une délivrance sous forme de
starter kit par les médecins
généralistes elle sera renforcée en 2023
avec une ouverture aux pharmaciens enfin
nous avons son vers une plus grande
accessibilité des trodes et autres au
test VIH ce modèle lancée il y a près de
11 ans maintenant à démontrer tout son
intérêt il est essentiel d'en améliorer
la flexibilité pour augmenter le réflexe
dépistage le covid nous a rappelé que
l'efficacité de la lutte contre les
pandémies doit faire l'objet d'une
approche concertée et multilatérale le
22 septembre dernier la France est ainsi
engagée à verser 1,6 milliards d'euros
au fond mondial de lutte contre le sida
la tuberculose et le paludisme pour
réaffirmer l'objectif d'un monde sans
sida à horizon 2030
je vous remercie madame la ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Julien rancoul
pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'Intérieur
dans la nuit du 27 au 28 octobre un
multiré
à l'hôpital Cochin et violée dans sa
chambre une patiente victime d'un
traumatisme crânien 3 monsieur le
ministre c'est le nombre d'obligations
de quitter le territoire adressé à cet
homme déjà connu des services de police
cet individu avait déjà été suspecté de
viol sur mineur en 2020 la dernière
auqtf le visant avait même été prononcé
avec application immédiate au mois de
juillet de cette année mais que fait
encore cet homme en France en 2019
Emmanuel Macron annoncé vouloir porter à
100% le taux d'exécution des eaux
d'exécutés F vous même monsieur le
ministre vous avez assuré à plusieurs
reprises que le gouvernement voulait
durcir l'application des occultés F et
rendre la vie impossible à ceux qui en
font l'objet
mais Monsieur le Ministre les Français
veulent des actes la réalité c'est que
le taux d'exécution des eaux qtf n'a
jamais été aussi faible seulement 5,6%
au premier semestre 2021 aujourd'hui
encore l'une de nos compatriotes paie le
prix de votre laxisme
et pourtant comme l'a proposé Marine Le
Pen il existe des moyens de pression
afin d'obtenir les fameux laisser passer
consulaires pour les renvoyer le blocage
des transferts d'argent vers les pays
d'origine l'arrêt des transferts des
aides au développement au développement
ou encore la limitation drastique du
nombre de visa accordé par pays alors je
vous pose la question quand comptez-vous
agir dernièrement vous avez proposé la
création d'un nouveau titre de séjour
visant régulariser des clandestins déjà
présents illégalement sur notre
territoire madame borne a annoncé
augmenté le nombre de visa délivrés Audi
étudiant algériens vous semblez
particulièrement ingénieux pour faire
rentrer des étrangers sur notre sol mais
beaucoup moins pour envoyer ce qui
pourrissent la vie des Français
expulser c'est protégés alors Monsieur
le Ministre quand allez-vous faire
appliquer toutes les auqtf afin de
protéger nos compatriotes je vous
remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Dominique Faure ministre délégué chargé
des collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
roucoule la politique d'éloignement a
connu une efficacité croissante entre
2017 et 2019
ce dynamique a ensuite été interrompu
sous l'effet de la fermeture des
frontières mesure sanitaires et mesure
diplomatiques de certains pays d'origine
en particulier du Maghreb nous faisons
déjà mieux que nos voisins européens sur
l'année 2021 nous avons procédé à 11630
éloignements dont 10.785 pour
l'Allemagne et 3230 pour l'Espagne en
2022 les éloignements sont en hausse de
20%
par rapport à 2021 depuis 2017 nous
avons expulsé plus de 700 étrangers
radicalisés
notre priorité absolue d'expulser les
étrangers
délinquants les étrangers constituant
une menace pour l'ordre public
représente depuis août 90% du public
placé en CMA 3500 étangs étrangers
constituant une menace pour l'ordre
public ont ainsi été éloignés du
territoire français depuis 2020
s'ajoutant au 700 étrangers radicalisés
expulsés depuis 2017 et au 88.000 titres
de séjour retirés ou refusé pour motif
d'ordre public le ministère de
l'intérieur des Outre-mer a donné des
instructions très claires au préfet via
une instruction du 17 novembre 2022 les
étrangers sous au qtf seront
systématiquement inscrits au fichiers
des personnes recherchées policiers au
gendarmes au douaniers de connaître
immédiatement la situation
administrative d'un étranger sous au qtf
en cas de contrôle d'identité sur la
voie publique permettant une mise à
exécution immédiate de l'éloignement
nous devons aller
encore plus loin le gouvernement aura
ainsi l'occasion de formuler ses
propositions pour mieux lutter encore
contre l'immigration irrégulière à
l'occasion du prochain débat sur
l'immigration au Parlement
je vous remercie madame la ministre
monsieur rencontre
vous ne répondez pas que faisait encore
cet homme en France merci
la parole est à monsieur Sylvain
carrière pour le groupe la France
insoumise
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
2022 en France c'est plus 10% sur
l'alimentation plus 15% sur les produits
alimentaires essentiels plus 15% pour
l'électricité et seulement 6% pour le
SMIC indexé à l'inflation nous avons
proposé le SMIC à 1600 euros vous l'avez
refusé nous proposons le blocage des
prix vous refusez encore
à macronie se chauffer ou manger il faut
choisir 10 millions de Français sous le
seuil de pauvreté selon le Secours
populaire 7 millions en insécurité
alimentaire voilà le vrai bilan de votre
politique
je continue une personne sur quatre
accueilli sur les banques alimentaires à
moins de 25 ans 83% des étudiants qui
fréquentent l'aide alimentaire ont
commencé depuis mars 2020 à Montpellier
au mois de novembre se sont mille
étudiants qui en ont bénéficié la
jeunesse a fait et fait la queue le soir
pour avoir un collier repas vous leur
annoncez des repas du CROUS à un euro
mais il se retrouve avec du pain
industriel assaisonné avec trois
morceaux de salade et deux miettes de
poulet
les miettes miroirs de la société du
ruissellement d'une élite qui se gavent
d'une élite qui refuse le rétablissement
de l'ISF qui défend corps et âme le
patron de Total qui se félicite de
gagner 6 millions d'euros en 2021 en
même temps des parents doivent rationner
leur propre enfant
le Secours populaire demandé 200
millions d'euros à coups de 49,3 vous
leur en accordé 117
des technocrates autour d'une table se
permettent de décider l'aide de qui
convient à ceux qui font la queue dans
le froid nous ne voulons plus d'aide
dans ce Pierre mais de la dignité pour
les Françaises et les Français alors
madame la Première ministre
quand allez-vous enfin écouter les
associations qui sont en première ligne
l'inflation revue dans les mois prévues
dans les mois à venir va atteindre de
nouveaux records la France est riche
alors qu'allez-vous enfin partager merci
beaucoup la parole est à Madame Agnès
Firma le Bodo ministre de la
l'organisation territoriale et des
professions de santé
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs le députés monsieur le député
Sylvain carrière l'inflation et la
hausse des prix de l'énergie ont en
effet un impact marqué sur les
associations de l'aide alimentaire et
leur près de 4 millions de bénéficiaires
les Banques Alimentaires feront monter
leurs inquiétudes et le gouvernement
agit la première loi de finances
rectificative vous cet été comporté
ainsi une enveloppe exceptionnelle de 55
millions d'euros en plus de 55 56
millions d'euros de la loi de finances
initiale cette enveloppe a permis de
protéger les associations fragilisées
par la hausse des prix des denrées et de
résoudre des difficultés particulières
par exemple liées au l'Audi infructueux
des marchés passés avec les crédits
européens j'ajoute sur ce point quatre
travail est en cours pour changer les
modalités de passation des marchés afin
de réduire la complexité et les risques
qui pèsent sur les acteurs une seconde
enveloppe exceptionnelle de 40 millions
d'euros supplémentaires a été dégagé
dans la seconde LFR VO il y a peu ces
fonds seront notamment mobilisés pour
lutter contre la précarité étudiante ce
sont ainsi 10 millions d'euros qui
seront dédiés au financement d'au moins
300.000 colis alimentaires permettant à
un étudiant de se nourrir pendant une
semaine en complément des repas CROUS à
un euro je rappelle par ailleurs que les
banques alimentaires bénéficient bien
évidemment de l'amortisseur et du
bouclier tarifaire enfin au-delà des
crédits d'urgence mobilisés l'action du
gouvernement en faveur de l'aide
alimentaire prend la forme d'un fond
pour une aide alimentaire durable doté
de 60 millions d'euros pour 2023 afin de
renforcer la qualité de l'aide
alimentaire et de soutenir des projets
locaux innovants vous voyez monsieur le
député le gouvernement agit
je vous remercie madame la ministre la
parole est à Madame Marina Ferrari pour
le groupe démocrate merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires le 22 novembre monsieur
le ministre vous avez annoncé la mise en
place d'un temps de formation et de
sensibilisation à destination des élus
locaux sur les questions de transition
écologique le groupe modem est
indépendant salut cette mesure les
collectivités locales étant en première
ligne pour engager les chantiers pour
accélérer la transition écologique selon
vos annonces les agences du ministère à
l'instar de Météo France de l'ADEME ou
de l'AFB serait chargé de ces formations
ma première question est simple monsieur
le ministre quels moyens et quelles
ressources humaines pourrait être
allouée à ses agences pour remplir cette
mission concernant l'objet de ces
formations vous avez annoncé je vous
cite qu'il s'agissait de regarder
territoire par territoire ce que sont
déjà les conséquences du dérèglement
climatique et la manière dont on peut
prendre des mesures pour l'atténuer et
s'y adapter si les élus locaux sont déjà
au fait de l'impact des changements
climatiques il apparaît en revanche
qu'il rencontre de véritables
difficultés pour appréhender les
enjolies au développement des énergies
renouvelables et de la ressource en eau
vulgarisation des enjeux de l'énergie
contrainte urbanistiques réglementation
connaissance des différentes solutions
techniques intégration des ENR au réseau
et financement sont par exemple autant
de sujets qui sont cruciaux à ce titre
il me semblerait important que les
volets développement des EnR et gestion
de l'eau soient intégrée à ces
formations avec un accompagnement
particulier sur ces sujets par des
formateurs dédiés il ne s'agit pas
évidemment de faire de nos élus locaux
des techniciens ou des ingénieurs mais
bien de leur donner les clés pour éviter
de tomber dans certains écueils et pour
s'assurer en amont de la réussite des
projets qu'il pourrait développer enfin
concernant le financement de ces
formations monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous nous préciser le ciel
viendront émarger ou non sur l'enveloppe
de 2 milliards d'euros à louer au fond
vert je vous remercie
bonjour je vous remercie Monsieur
Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée Ferrari en marge du Salon des
mers j'ai effectivement
eu l'occasion d'indiquer notre volonté
de lancer une formation partout en
France à destination de tous les maires
précisément autour de ces questions sur
le dérèglement climatique et la
préservation de la biodiversité on n'a
pas imaginé un plan en chambre on s'est
basé sur un département de ce pays qui
l'a lancé le département de l'Indre 241
communes ou 250 élus c'est à dire un peu
plus que tous les mers ont suivi une
formation qui a été organisée par la
préfecture avec l'appui du département
et qui s'est appuyé sur les forces vives
du ministère des agents de l'ADEME des
agents de Météo France de l'ofb et pour
répondre à votre question on a par
exemple 35 intervenants climat au sein
de météo
ces mers qui ont décidé de suivre ces
sessions de formation on n'a pas fait la
lecture du rapport du GIEC à haute voix
on a été démontré ce qui était déjà les
conséquences sur le territoire par
rapport aux écarts en termes de moyenne
de température on a fêté des élus qui
s'étaient lancés dans des politiques
d'îlotes fraîcheur on a insisté sur ce
qui était des solutions concrètes
appréhendables du terrain d'une écologie
du concret je retiens votre suggestion
de faire en sorte que au-delà de ces
questions sur l'adaptation sur la
biodiversité on puisse faire en sorte
d'avoir des zooms sur les questions qui
sont en train de monter la question de
l'eau pour lequel nous avons lancé fin
septembre avec Bérengère Couillard et
marcéno le chantier de sa gestion
réutilisation des eaux usées
préservation des laps phréatiques
volonté de limiter les pertes et les
fuites et l'autre sujet sur les énergies
renouvelables où on sait qu'on a un
enjeu de pédagogie sur la capacité qu'il
y a à être à la fois capable de regarder
la manière dont on peut avancer mesurer
les freins et construire les consensus
locaux dont on a besoin
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Alain David pour
le groupe socialiste
monsieur le ministre de l'économie et
des finances un mouvement de grève
d'ampleur touche plusieurs sites de
l'entreprise Sanofi dans celui d'en
Barrès près de Bordeaux et de
Val-de-Reuil ce mouvement de grève a été
reconduit au sein des sites Sanofi dont
une partie des personnels réclame
toujours des revalorisations salariales
ainsi que la titularisation des deux
tiers des contrats précaires en disant
Sanofi aperçu plus d'un milliard d'euros
d'aide publique de l'État via le CIR et
le cice ce sujet est donc au carrefour
de plusieurs problématiques
préoccupantes la pénurie de certains
médicaments d'une part et des super
profits et logiques financières d'autre
part Sanofi est en effet entrée dans une
logique financière malsaine au lieu de
se concentrer sur son métier de
recherche et de production de
médicaments
elle avait déjà choquée en poursuivant
ses licenciements alors qu'elle réalise
des profits importants à l'été 2022
c'était l'annonce de fermeture du site
de recherche et développement de chimie
Mazarin avec ses 1600 emplois avant cela
en 2020 il y a eu la fermeture du site
de vitry-alfortville spécialisé dans les
biotechniques dans les biotechnologies
dans la bioproduction et la sécurité des
médicaments dans de la même manière
pendant cette crise sanitaire des grands
espoirs avait été placés avant d'être
cruellement déçu dans la capacité de
l'entreprise de produire un vaccin
viable
ma question sera donc simple quelle
contrepartie le gouvernement entend
exigé de l'entreprise Sanofi en matière
de maintien de l'emploi de juste
répartition des profits envers les
salariés et d'investissement dans la
recherche et la production des
médicaments dans notre pays a
cruellement besoin
[Applaudissements]
cure ministre délégué chargé de
l'Industrie
merci les députés monsieur le député à
David vous m'interrogez sur un conflit
qui affecte aujourd'hui une partie de
l'entreprise Sanofi y compris vous
l'avez dit dans votre circonscription au
sujet des salaires donc je voudrais
commencer à rappeler par rappeler à
l'Assemblée nationale une étude qui a
été publiée aujourd'hui et qui a été
mentionnée par les échos qui dit que la
France est le meilleur élève du pouvoir
d'achat en Europe
entre 2019 et 2022 le pouvoir d'achat en
France Mesdames et Messieurs les
parlementaires il a augmenté d'un
véhicule 5% alors qu'il stagnait en
Allemagne et qu'il baissait en Italie au
Royaume-Uni et en Espagne cela pour vous
rappeler que grâce aux mesures notamment
il y a été votées par cette majorité
l'inflation est aujourd'hui plus faible
en France qu'elle est nulle part
ailleurs en Europe et grâce aux efforts
des entreprises qui ont continué à créer
de l'emploi le pouvoir d'achat des
salariés français a progressé
est-ce que ça veut dire qu'il faut
s'arrêter là la réponse est évidemment
non et moi j'engage comme le
gouvernement dans son ensemble l'échelle
d'entreprise à se saisir des outils
qu'il a encore ont été votés par cette
majorité je vous rappelle que cette
majorité cet été a voté le triplement de
la prime de partage de la valeur donc
quelques mois plus de 730 000 salariés
j'y viens on bénéficié l'intéressement
la participation là encore votée par
cette majorité c'est 60% de
bénéficiaires en plus et pour les
salaires monsieur peu puisque vous me
relancez là dessus vous le savez même si
je ne souhaite en aucun cas m'immiscer
dans des négociations salariales
particulières vous le savez monsieur le
député sanofi a proposé une hausse des
rémunérations pour l'ensemble des
salariés en 2023 de plus de 7%, une
partie en salaire une partie en prime
justement votée par cette majorité
j'engage les parties de Sanofi à
poursuivre cette négociation donc
j'espère effectivement qu'elle sera
conclusive merci
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Jean-Claude Rault
pour
pour le logis
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de la
Santé j'ai lu dans une tribune du Monde
que la santé mentale était l'enjeu du
21e siècle pourtant près de 30% des
postes de psychiatre sont vacants en
France et je n'ose commenter l'état de
la pédopsychiatrie hier après deux
heures passées auprès de psychiatre et
de médecins voici les mots qui m'ont
frappé abandons incompréhension
épuisement ce sont hélas les mêmes mots
qui résonnent aux oreilles de chacune et
chacun de mes collègues sur leur
territoire dans l'hôpital de
Loire-Atlantique ou suroccupation et
pénurie médicale sont le lot quotidien
ou des médecins et paramédicaux
sévères-tu pourtant a mené un travail et
des projets de qualité les demandes sans
fin d'adaptation l'accroissement des
missions les décisions méprisantes de
l'ARS créent l'épuisement et la
dégradation des soins
quand faute de soignants une unité ferme
dans la Sarthe ce sont 21 patients qui
ont dû être qui ont dû être accueilli
cet été dans cet hôpital malgré le
sous-effectif déjà criant patient qui
rentre chez eux une fois le temps
d'hospitalisation effectuée sans le
suivi approprié demain l'absence de
médecin en Mayenne en Vendée ou ailleurs
pour être entraîner d'autres
transhumance de patients dans des
conditions aussi uniques et que dire de
celles et ceux qui ne peuvent même pas
accéder aux soins ou des enfants pris en
charge dans des services pour adultes
faute de place
madame la ministre quand des médecins
qui ont fait le choix de l'hôpital
public et de la psychiatrie vous disent
qu'il et elle ne sont plus capables de
penser navigue à vue en fonction des
arrêts de travail ne gère que l'urgence
et les fermetures de lit quand les
équipes entières vous parlent de guerre
au quotidien sans être ni entendu ni
reconnu ni soutenu que leur
répondez-vous allez-vous enfin faire de
la santé mentale une priorité alors
qu'une personne sur cinq est touchée
chaque année par un trouble psychique au
lieu de laisser la psychiatrie continuer
à se délabrer géré par les technocrates
qui ont amené notre système de santé au
bord du gouffre
merci beaucoup mon cher collègue la
parole est à Madame Agnès Firmin le Bodo
ministre délégué chargé de
l'organisation territoriale et des
professions de santé madame la
Présidente Mesdames mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
jean-claudeau la psychiatrie est plus
largement la prise en charge de la santé
mentale est un sujet d'importance comme
vous le rappelez qui fait l'objet de
toute mon attention les conséquences de
la crise covid notamment ont fortement
impacté cette santé mentale qui est plus
que jamais une priorité le ministère a
pleinement conscience des difficultés
qu'on rencontre actuellement les
psychiatres ce matin ont été reçus au
ministère de la Santé les quatre
syndicats qui ont appelé à la grève nous
avons convenu qu'un cycle de réunions et
de travail sur les sujets propres à la
psychiatrie s'ouvrira à partir de début
janvier avec les représentants de la
profession le ministre François Braun
les recevra dans ce cadre dans le cadre
d'un dialogue social nourri nous
souhaitons pouvoir établir un plan
d'ampleur pour améliorer les conditions
d'exercices et conduire les chantiers
structurels de modernisation de la
profession
structurelles sont déjà en cours la
réforme du financement de la psychiatrie
qui a pour objectif de réduire les
inégalités entre les territoires et de
redonner des marges de développement à
la psychiatrie notamment publique la
réforme des autorisations pour renforcer
le maillage territorial prochainement
sera effectué un premier bilan des
Assises de la psychiatrie et de la santé
mentale enfin parce que l'enjeu du
soutien à la pédopsychiatrie et majeure
les assises de la pédiatrie et de la
santé mentale permettront d'accélérer
les actions dans ce domaine enfin les
enveloppes financières importantes au
soutien du secteur ont été débloqués de
façon pérenne notamment en 2020 une
enveloppe de 110 millions d'euros et de
nouveau en 2021 dans le cadre du Ségur
investissement des soutiens au projet de
modernisation assez nécessaire des
établissements psychiatriques les
mesures de soutien général à l'hôpital
bénéficient aussi au service de
psychiatrie enfin le CNR en santé qui se
déroule actuellement dans tous les
territoires permet de développer les
leviers locaux pour répondre à ces en
jeu en créant des alliances aux préparer
des réalités de terrain vous l'avez
signalé l'enjeu de la prise en charge de
la psychiatrie est un enjeu majeur c'est
pour cela que nous activons tous les
leviers pour refonder et transformer
notre système de santé et l'adapter aux
défis auxquels nous faisons face
ambition dans laquelle la santé mentale
et la psychiatrie sont des priorités
structurantes et transversales merci
beaucoup madame la ministre la parole
est à Monsieur Lionel Vuibert pour le
comprenaissances merci madame la
Présidente je tresse ma question à
Monsieur le Ministre chargé de
l'Industrie monsieur le ministre comme
vous le savez la crise énergétique que
nous traversons un pacte fortement la
trésorerie des entreprises avec des prix
près de 10 fois supérieurs à ceux de
2020 les entreprises grandes
consommatrices d'énergie
qui doivent actuellement négocier leur
ou qui doivent actuellement renégocier
leur contrat connaissent de réelles
difficultés à tel point que nombreuses
sont celles qui voient leur équilibre
économiques mis en péril néanmoins dans
un environnement conjoncturel difficile
marqué par une succession de choc
l'activité continue à résister
globalement nous le devons gouvernement
et à sa majorité qui ont très tôt mesuré
toutes les conséquences de cette
inflation en engageant sur trois ans
pour près de 110 milliards d'euros
d'aide pour les ménages et les
entreprises le 19 novembre dernier ont
été présentés les modalités de
simplification et de renforcement des
différents dispositifs d'aide aux
entreprises collectivités et
associations ainsi parmi les mesures
phares le bouclier tarifaire qui permet
de plafonner la hausse des factures
d'électricité des TPE à 4% 2022 et 15%
en 2023 ou encore l'amortisseur
électricité destiné au PME il faut
également citer le guichet d'aide au
paiement des factures de gaz et
d'électricité pour les ETI et les
grandes entreprises
or ces dispositifs peuvent être encore
améliorés notamment ce qui concerne les
entreprises créées après le premier
décembre 2021 comme c'est le cas pour
quelques métazer ardennais ou encore
celle en difficulté du fait notamment
d'une exposition forte à la concurrence
internationale monsieur le ministre
quelle mesure complémentaire pourrait
être mise en œuvre pour aider les
entreprises en grande difficulté ou non
concernés par les dispositifs existants
je vous remercie merci beaucoup la
parole est à Monsieur Roland Lescure
ministre délégué en charge de
l'Industrie
merci mesdames messieurs les députés
monsieur le députés Viber merci de
m'interroger sur ce secteur industriel
que vous connaissez bien puisque vous
avez pratiqué longtemps et que vous êtes
élu d'un département les Ardennes
industrielles hier aujourd'hui et je
n'en doute pas demain vous nous
interrogez sur les aides que nous avons
adopté ça me permet de rappeler à
l'ensemble de la représentation
nationale que depuis une dizaine de
jours nous avons simplifié nous avons
amplifié nous avons prolongé le
dispositif d'aide et j'engage
véritablement toutes les entreprises de
France et pas seulement industrielles à
se connecter sur le site impôts gouv.fr
il existe un simulateur très simple qui
vous permet d'évaluer en temps réel le
montant d'aide auquel vous aurez droit
en 2022 et en 2023 j'étais la semaine
dernière en cas de la semaine dans
l'industrie dans le Loiret pas chez vous
monsieur le député mais pas très loin
non plus visité notamment l'imprimeur
Mory que nous connaissons bien pas très
loin
et qui et qui verra sa facture
énergétique payée à peu près un tiers
grâce à ses aides en 2023 22 et sans
doute encore en 2023 si les prix de
l'énergie restent là où ils sont est-ce
que pour autant nous couvrons toutes les
situations vous l'avez mentionné il
reste sans doute encore quelques trous à
combler notamment les entreprises qui
n'existaient pas en 2021 et pour
lesquels du coup la facture
d'énergétique est évidemment difficile à
remplir nous sommes en discussion avec
la Commission européenne pour voir si et
comment on peut compléter ce dispositif
pour bien les toucher ou si il faudra
passer
d'autres dispositifs mais je tiens
véritablement à rassurer la
représentation nationale nous sommes là
pour soutenir notre industrie à la fois
dans la transition majeure qui va
l'amener à se décarboner dans les 10 20
et 30 années qui viennent mais aussi à
passer l'hiver dans les 10 20 30 jours
qui suivent merci monsieur le député
merci beaucoup monsieur ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Damien Maudet pour
le groupe la France insoumise
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse aux ministres de la Santé
François Braun en France peut-on soigner
encore nos enfants s'il faut consulter
un pédiatre impossible il y en a plus
s'il faut aller aux urgences impossible
il n'y a plus de place maintenant même
pour soigner une angine impossible il
n'y a plus de médicaments pourtant en
mars 2020 le président Macron promettait
ce que révèle cette pandémie c'est qu'il
est des biens et des services qui
doivent être placés en dehors des lois
du marché déléguer notre alimentation
notre protection notre capacité à
soigner est une folie deux ans après ces
belles paroles sur nos médicaments ou en
sommes-nous à Limoges comme ailleurs les
pharmaciens le disent si on a sur la
même ordonnance amoxicilline doliprane
en sachet on ne peut rien donner en
vérité sous votre gouvernement la
situation ne fait que se dégrader on est
passé de 400 2016 à 2200 pénuries de
médicaments en 2021 la vérité monsieur
le ministre c'est que deux ans après les
promesses notre pays est à poil la
vérité c'est qu'aujourd'hui 80% des
molécules pour faire ces médicaments
sont produits en Chine et en Inde la
vérité c'est que là les productions
s'arrêtent parce que les multinationales
jugent ces médicaments peu rentables la
vérité c'est qu'après avoir regardé
partir c'est même multinationales vous
les regardez d'argent public en espérant
les faire revenir plus de médecins plus
de soignants et maintenant plus de
médicaments monsieur le ministre quand
allez-vous reprendre la main pour nos
vies pour notre industrie comme le
disait Emmanuel Macron la logique dans
laquelle que vous perpétuez une folie
dans la septième puissance mondiale
comment se fait-il qu'on soit plus
capable de produire une simple boîte
d'amoxicilline comme celle-ci dans la
septième puissance mondiale nous avons
besoin d'un ministre de la Santé pas des
pénuries
je vous remercie
Monsieur Roland Lescure ministre en
charge de l'Industrie merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames Messieurs que nous
n'avons pas le droit de brandir des
objets dans l'hémicycle et vous le savez
très bien mon cher collègues merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames Messieurs
les Députés monsieur le député Damien
Maudet
vous avez souhaité dans votre question
inquiéter les Françaises et les Français
ça ne me surprend pas
c'est votre fond de commerce et donc je
voudrais commencer ma réponse par les
rassurer aujourd'hui nos concitoyens qui
se voient prescrire du paracétamol ou de
l'amoxicilline se voit délivré du
paracétamol ou de l'amoxicilline qu'ils
en soi rassurés pour autant existe-t-il
des tensions sur le marché la réponse
est oui parce que dans le monde entier
depuis quatre ans la consommation de
médicaments a été extrêmement volatile
et on sait tous et toutes pourquoi le
gouvernement a réagi très vite à ces
situations de tension qui se sont fait
jour en grande partie d'ailleurs parce
que nous disposons d'un dispositif
d'alerte trois semaines unique en France
qui nous a permis d'être alerté très tôt
dès le mois de juillet 2022 nous avons
contingenté les stocks au niveau des
industriels pour distribuer
équitablement les pharmacies sur le
territoire
depuis octobre 2022 les grossistes
répartiteurs ne peuvent plus exporter
des médicaments en question et nous
avons augmenté la production de
paracétamol en France avec des usines
qui tournent aujourd'hui 24 heures sur
24 et 7 jours sur 7 nous avons distribué
en officines nous avons ça nous sommes
assurés pardon que la distribution de
piscine serait calé sur le besoin
médical nous travaillons en cours pour
améliorer l'usage des antibiotiques pour
reprendre un slogan célèbre les
antibiotiques c'est pas automatique pour
autant nous sommes d'accord avec vous
sur un point nous devons renforcer la
souveraineté industrielle française et
contrairement à vous qui investivez nous
agissons vous le savez nous avons
annoncé la réinstallation de la
production de principes actifs en Isère
non loin de Grenoble par l'entreprise
séquence ce projet est en cours et on
devrait avoir des premières livraisons
en 2025 merci merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur modèle
en vérité en vérité aujourd'hui c'est
vous qui inquiétez les Français parce
que vous leur promettez de continuer
comme avant si vous prévoyez de
relocaliser une partie de la production
c'est à peine 5% de tous les médicaments
essentiels il nous faudra donc 200 ans
pour localiser tous les médicaments
essentiels à ce rythme-là
la parole
la parole est à Monsieur Jordan Guitton
pour le groupe rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre délégué chargé des
transports RER B la galère quotidienne
ou encore allez et retour nous avons
cumulé plus de 6 heures de retard pour
un trajet trois Paris dans mon
département de l'Aube voilà le quotidien
de 73% des Français qui utilisent les
bus les métros et train pour leur
dépassement quotidien ces témoignages
illustrent les difficultés rencontrées
par tous les usagers des transports en
commun stress fatigue retard pour aller
travailler sans évoquer l'insécurité les
Français sont obligés d'utiliser un
service où les retards et les
suppressions s'accumulent d'autant plus
que les prix ne font que s'envoler comme
le Pass Navigo le ticket de métro le TGV
et bientôt les TER tout augmente cette
situation n'est plus tenable entre nos
concitoyens de la France urbaine qui
sont obligés d'utiliser des transports
en commun dégradés pour aller travailler
et les oublier de la France rurale qui
ne peuvent tout simplement plus aller la
politique de transport du gouvernement
continue de s'effondrer depuis de
nombreuses années comme dans beaucoup
d'autres domaines la France perd sa
place pionnière au profit d'une gestion
de crise permanente que même les
cabinets de conseils n'arrivent pas à
déjouer alors face à cela Emmanuel
Macron fuit sa responsabilité
aujourd'hui en annonçant à grands plan
de RER pour les métropoles dans 10 ans
au lieu de faire un gland grand plan
urbain et rural pour le transport
maintenant les Français ne veulent pas
d'un président youtube avec une vérité
avec une vision parisienne mais d'un
président qui facilite leur quotidien
avec une vision nationale alors monsieur
le ministre mes questions sont simples
que comptez-vous faire pour redonner aux
Français un service public de qualité
avec des transports en commun sécurisés
et à l'heure quand allez-vous augmenter
la fréquence de déserte aux heures de
pointe et maintenir les petites lignes
rurales enfin allez-vous augmenter la
qualité et non le prix du service public
des transports je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Christophe
Béchu ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires madame la présidente Madame
et Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
député Guiton
c'est précisément un plan complet
national pas uniquement centré sur
l'Île-de-France ou sur tel ou tel
territoire que nous apprêtons à vous
présenter une méthode qui est exactement
celle que nous avons décrite depuis des
mois la présentation par le comité
d'orientation des infrastructures après
un tour de France qui a commencé il y a
déjà plusieurs mois de toutes les
infrastructures qui sont attendues dans
les 13 régions métropolitaines et
au-delà ce plan il va d'abord s'appuyer
sur des investissements
massifs sur le ferroviaire c'est bien
entendu la pierre angulaire de la
planification écologique qui sera
déclinée par la première ministre des
dizaines de milliards d'euros avec à la
fois l'action qui sera mis vous avez
raison sur la régénération des
transports du quotidien et des lignes
nous avons depuis cinq ans augmenter les
moyens que nous y consacrons il faut
encore les augmenter avec en particulier
certains sujets comme les postes de
signalisation automatique et le rTMS en
parallèle à côté de ce dispositif qui va
des trains d'équilibre du territoire
jusqu'à ces régénérations de petites
lignes au train de nuit au fret le
président de la République a dévoilé
vendredi un des éléments socle de ce
projet que sont les RER métropolitains
sur lesquels nous travaillons avec la
SNCF depuis plusieurs mois à partir
d'une idée les transports ça représente
30 % des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre dans ce la voiture individuelle
représente 60% alors que le train pour
10% de voyageurs et pour 9% des
marchandises transportées c'est 0,3% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
augmenter cette part ça nécessite
d'aller investir là où les Français
vivent le plan que nous aurons
l'occasion de décliner pour lequel nous
réunirons les territoires en début
d'année pour leur préciser la hauteur de
la contribution de l'État concernera
plus de 10 millions de Français qui
vivent dans ces zones denses et sur
lesquelles nous aurons l'occasion
d'intervenir
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur Guiton merci monsieur le
ministre pour votre réponse de techno je
vous invite tout simplement à reprendre
les transports en commun et à venir
vivre le quotidien des Français et la
galère qui vivent au quotidien
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur le député merci pour votre
réponse de politicien
[Applaudissements]
alors la parole est à Monsieur Francis
Dubois pour le groupe les républicains
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'Économie des Finances de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
monsieur le ministre comme vous devez le
savoir on rassemblement historique se
tient à proximité de l'Assemblée
nationale organisé à l'initiative des
artisans bouchés charcutiers ils sont
venus de la France entière pour
manifester leur désarroi ces artisans
n'ont pourtant pas la culture de la
manifestation cela fait 20 ans que la
profession n'a pas manifesté depuis la
crise de lavage folle en effet il
subissent de plein fouet l'explosion des
prix de l'énergie si bien que les 80 000
femmes et hommes du secteur alerte
aujourd'hui sur la gravité de la
situation le gouvernement n'a pas saisi
l'ampleur des difficultés de la
profession les conséquences économiques
et sociales imposées par cette crise
énergétique son dramatique si le
gouvernement ne prend pas ses
responsabilités dans les semaines qui
viennent nous assisterons collectivement
à la mort de nombreuses entreprises les
dispositifs actuels ne pas en réalité de
terrain 40% des entreprises se trouvent
dans une véritable zone blanche et ne
peuvent bénéficier du bouclier tarifaire
de plus la mesure de l'amortisseur
électrique prévue pour 2023 pour les non
éligibles et plus qu'un suffisante
aujourd'hui la tarification est en
hausse de près de 400 %, vos mesures
pour la période d'octobre décembre ne
couvriront ainsi que 20 à 30% de
l'augmentation elles sont donc
inadaptées et
inefficaces pour ces artisans les
augmentations du prix de l'électricité
viendrait réduire drastiquement leurs
résultats leur rémunération leur
capacité à rembourser les emprunts qui
plus est dans un contexte où les prix
des matières premières ont augmenté de
12%, sans compter les difficultés de
recrutement au sein de la filière et ce
malgré une revalorisation des salaires
de plus de 7%, c'est une profession à
bout de souffle et en danger qui
manifeste aujourd'hui pouvez-vous donc
monsieur le ministre vous engagez à
prendre des mesures réellement efficaces
pour protéger nos artisans et TPE
le confort du lien social notamment en
zone rurale
[Applaudissements]
tourisme
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député Dubois face à la hausse des prix
de l'énergie le gouvernement agit et
continuera d'agir premièrement nous
avons un bouclier tarifaire qui couvre
au moment où je vous parle la moitié de
nos TPE au prix du bouclier tarifaire
nous avons il y a une dizaine de jours
rouverts sur un pot.gouv.fr le
dispositif le guichet qui permet à nos
artisans boulangers boucher et bien
d'autres d'être aidé avec un RIB en main
et deux factures d'énergie sur 2022 à
partir du moment où ça représente 3% de
leur chiffre d'affaires 2021 et à
compter du 1er janvier 2023 plus simple
ça n'est pas possible il n'y aura rien à
faire pour pouvoir bénéficier d'une
prise en charge mesdames Messieurs les
parlementaires qui se fera à 50% de la
part énergie
nos artisans bouchés boulangers monsieur
Dubois vous avez posé votre question
avec un vrai engagement et un sens des
responsabilités à l'endroit des artisans
je vais vous dire que vendredi encore
j'étais avec les boulangers demain je
serai avec les bouchers je ne suis pas
du genre à me défiler et Bruno Le Maire
non plus nous avons leur facture en main
nous sommes en train de regarder sur des
multiples cas très concrètement si il
faut peut-être adapter le dispositif
vous avez dit monsieur Dubois il faut
que le gouvernement prenne ses
responsabilités je veux vous dire
monsieur Dubois que le gouvernement les
prendra et qu'il lui accompagnera nos
artisans et que si il faut faire un peu
plus nous le ferons mais de grâce avant
de dire il faut faire plus et je sais
que vous êtes de bonne foi éprouvons
déjà les dispositifs mis en oeuvre
testons déjà ce qui est mis en place il
y a 10 milliards d'euros sur la table
aujourd'hui nous avons toujours pris nos
responsabilités s'il faut plus nous
ferons plus mais essayons déjà d'obtenir
les aide en place un pot.gouv.fr et si
contrairement à d'autres vous êtes ici
pour accompagner les artisans
donnez-leur ces informations dites moi
si ça ne suffit pas et nous ferons plus
je vous remercie madame la ministre
la parole est à Monsieur romain Daubié
pour le groupe démocrate
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'Économie des Finances la
simplification administrative pour les
particuliers ou pour les entreprises
doit être un objectif pour tous les
formalités administratives pèsent sur
l'activité des entreprises en
particulier les TPE et les PME pour
faciliter la création au développement
d'entreprise cette majorité a décidé à
travers la loi du pacte en mai 2019 de
rassembler les Réseaux de centres de
formalités des entreprises en aguichet
unique ce guichet unique doit permettre
à toutes les entreprises quelle que soit
leur forme juridique et leur domaine
d'activité de déclarer en ligne toutes
les formalités qu'elle doivent remplir
auprès des différents organismes
création
modifications des pots de compte tout
peut se faire en ligne sur un même site
facilitant ainsi la vie des
entrepreneurs ce n'est pas moins de 56
CERFA qui sont remplacés par ce guichet
unique oui à cette simplification
confié alien pays ce guichet deviendra
obligatoire à compter le 1er janvier
prochain pour encourager la transition
il est accessible depuis le 1er avril
2021 cependant cependant forçait de
constater quelques semaines de
l'échéance le site actuel ne semble pas
satisfaisant certaines entreprises ne
sont pas reconnues le site demande des
documents qui ne correspondent pas en la
forme juridique de l'entreprise cela
empêche les entrepreneurs de réaliser
les formalités le guichet unique ne
semble donc pas en mesure de remplacer
entièrement les CFE au 1er janvier
prochain
en réalité il semble que plutôt que
d'accélérer la création ce guichet
ralentissent les marches ainsi nous
pouvons inquiétons sur le lancement trop
précoce un outil inabouti un mauvais
outil j'en viens à question monsieur le
ministre pensez-vous que les
améliorations nécessaires pourront te
rapporter d'ici le premier janvier pour
garantir aux usagers un système efficace
ne faut-il pas décaler sa mise en place
deux mois six mois une coexistence des
guichets physiques et du guichet edit
comme si avec aujourd'hui ne paie pas
être prolongé merci
beaucoup la parole est à Madame Olivia
Grégoire ministre délégué chargé des
petits et moyennes entreprises du
commerce de l'artisanat et du tourisme
merci Monsieur Daubié pour votre
question et je me permettrai par la même
de répondre aussi au président maitei
puisqu'il s'avère que le président
Mattei m'a déjà sollicité alerté sur le
guichet aux entreprises
vous avez dit les formalités pèsent sur
les entreprises je dirais même pour
l'avoir été elle pèse sur le moral des
entrepreneurs et aussi sur leur marge
brute puisque le temps d'un entrepreneur
c'est souvent du développement et de
l'argent combien de nos entrepreneurs
ont été découragés par ces formalités
souvent chronophages ça n'est donc pas
un hasard si la loi pacte que nous avons
été nombreux à voter lors de la
précédente monde à être sûr à
effectivement mis en oeuvre un guichet
unique dont beaucoup d'entrepreneurs ont
rêvé pour créer ses dés transmettre
changer son adresse changer de statut
changer son immatriculation bref c'était
un parcours du combattant oui c'est un
changement de culture majeur et oui
c'est un projet majeur vous l'avez
rappelé pas moins des deux tiers des
formalités administratives dans notre
pays sont encore en format papier et
nous avons six réseaux de différents qui
s'y emploient donc c'est effectivement
un projet d'ampleur qui dit projet
d'ampleur dit préparation d'ampleur et
donc si je ne sous-estime pas le
changement de culture je veux vous dire
à quel point au ministère de l'économie
est des finances avec Bruno Le Maire
nous sommes mobilisés Linky tous les
acteurs impliqués font un suivi
quotidien des campagnes tests à partir
de cas fictif on redirige déjà au
maximum les déclarants vers ce nouveau
guichet pour augmenter les flux réels
nous avons prévu comme tout nouveau
service aussi de mettre en place une
procédure de secours pour les premiers
mois de l'année 2023 que nous prêtons au
ministère de l'économie et des finances
en cas de dysfonctionnement pour tel ou
telle formalité sur le guichet je veux
aussi vous rassurer en vous disant que
nous avons mis en place un système
d'assistance en ligne pas uniquement sur
le web mais aussi au téléphone pour les
premiers pas des entrepreneurs qui
pourraient déstabilisés par ce nouveau
guichet des 2023 le temps est terminé
mon bureau est ouvert nous sommes
vigilants et je connais l'intérêt du
groupe modem sur ce sujet on est très
vigilant je vous remercie merci beaucoup
madame la ministre la parole est à
Madame Mathilde
ignet pour le groupe la France insoumise
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres collègues ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Marc
fenault ministre de l'Agriculture et de
la souveraineté alimentaire les Français
sont pris à la gorge depuis plusieurs
mois ils angoissent dans l'attente des
factures d'énergie et n'arrive plus à
remplir leurs caddie la baisse du
pouvoir d'achat des ménages les
contraints à s'orienter vers des
produits moins chers et souvent de moins
bonne qualité
vous refusez d'indexer les salaires sur
l'inflation vous refusez de bloquer les
prix de l'énergie comment voulez-vous
que les Français et les moyens de
privilégier les produits de qualité
issus de l'agriculture durable une
situation qui menace des paysans et
paysannes français qui ont fait l'effort
de la transition vers des pratiques plus
respectueuses de l'environnement des
animaux et de l'humain certains groupes
comme Lactalis ou SODIAL freinent la
conversion de leur producteurs des
classes des volumes de production ou
encore paye moins bien les produits bio
que les produits conventionnels
après plusieurs années de croissance la
filière bio traverse une véritable crise
pour les éleveurs de port bio les ventes
ont reculé de 15 à 20% en 7 mois une
crise qui affecte aussi les magasins bio
après avoir encaissé un recul de son
chiffre d'affaires de 10 % le réseau
Rennais scarabée Biocoop a été placé en
redressement judiciaire menaçant 204
emplois si la grande distribution se
détourne des produits bio et que les
magasins spécialisés sont en danger que
reste-t-il au producteurs pour certains
70% de leur débouchés risquent de
disparaître il y a aussi la
multiplication des labels comme le
trèfle HVE le consommateur perd
confiance et ne s'y retrouve plus et je
le comprends
que comptez-vous faire pour soutenir nos
paysans et paysannes en agriculture bio
ou en appellation d'origine protégée et
rendre accessible aux consommateurs une
alimentation plus saine et de meilleure
qualité je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur max et ministre
de l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députés Henniez plusieurs réponses à
la question vous posez d'abord les faits
la surface en bio à la doubler entre
2017 et 2022 pour atteindre plus de 2,78
millions d'hectares ce qui fait de la
France la première surface convertie en
bio de l'Europe de l'Union européenne où
l'on devrait collectivement s'en
féliciter deuxième élément qu'est-ce que
nous faisons nous ont d'abord au travers
de la politique agricole commune au
travers du programme ambition bio une
augmentation de 30 de plus de 30% des
crédits qui vont être alloués à la
conversion en bio troisième élément ce
que nous faisons aussi dans le cadre ce
que nous avons fait aussi en termes
d'accompagnement dans le cadre du plan
de relance pour faire en sorte que l'on
puisse accompagner mieux les
agriculteurs bio dans la transformation
de leur modèle quatrième élément que je
veux dire le Crédit Impôt bio qui permet
aux agriculteurs biologiques qui sont
déjà convertis de pouvoir maintenir leur
activité on est passé de 75 millions
d'euros à 109 millions d'euros de 75
millions d'euros à 109 millions d'euros
alors par ailleurs nous avons un sujet
structurel et un sujet conjoncturel le
sujet conjoncturel c'est le sujet de
l'inflation qui pèse effectivement sur
les ménages même si comme ça a été dit
par plusieurs collègues on a une
inflation plus basse que d'autres et
donc il y a une dégradation dans les
choix des consommateurs de produits bio
vers d'autres types de produits et donc
on a besoin de travailler sur ce sujet
là puis on a un sujet structurel c'est
l'offre s'est développée il faut que
désormais la demande soit au rendez-vous
nous avions une croissance à deux
chiffres sur les produits bio peut-être
que cette croissance n'était pas assez
atteint sa limite et donc nous avons
besoin de travailler sur la demande et à
faire en sorte que dans une stratégie de
communication nous puissions montrer les
vertus des de l'agriculture biologique
dans le modèle agricole français puis
par ailleurs vous me permettrait dire
cessons d'opposer les modèles les labels
la haute valeur environnementale le bio
tout ça et la complétude l'agriculture
tout conventionnelle c'est la complétu
de l'agriculture française il faut
respecter l'ensemble des producteurs et
faire en sorte que chacun puisse trouver
sa place en termes de rémunération
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à monsieur le Président
Chassagne pour le groupe
gauche-démocrate et républicaine
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre ma question
concerne les territoires les plus
pauvres de la République dans lesquels
les crises actuelles ont des effets des
multipliés dans les outre-mer la vie
n'est plus seulement chère elle est hors
de prix tout augmente aucun secteur
n'était épargné déjà hors norme la
grande pauvreté fait des ravages au cri
d'alarme et de souffrance de nos
concitoyens le gouvernement a répondu
parce qu'il appelle un ou Dino du
pouvoir d'achat mais il ne cesse d'être
différé les monopoles et l'économie des
containers résiste comme toujours cet
épisode révèle le manque datation une
légèreté du pouvoir central puisque le
même silence se retrouve pour les
énergies renouvelables rien de prévu
alors que les outre-mer regorgent de
potentialité de gisement de projet à
temps conscience que c'est leur objectif
d'autonomie énergétique qu'on en
travaille ainsi et que dire et que dire
du mépris de la majorité qui préfère
camper sur des positions idéologiques
plutôt que de remédier au désir médicaux
et au manque de soignants dont souffre
cruellement nos concitoyens d'outre-mer
madame la Première ministre il faut
changer de méthode adopter une démarche
qui part des territoires modifiez votre
regard et admettre que ce sont bien les
outre-mer qui font de la France une
puissance maritime une puissance
spatiale un joyau mondial de la
biodiversité
des trophées qui ne suffit pas de
brandir fièrement dans les conférences
internationales oui les femmes et les
hommes qui vivent sur ces terres
aspirent au développement ce qui suppose
de leur facilité l'action foncier à
l'eau aux environnements régionaux en un
mot l'accès à leur avenir madame la
Première ministre le statu quo n'est
plus tenable et les vieilles recettes ne
font qu'amplifier la colère qui grandit
énormément l'état sera-t-il présent à ce
rendez-vous historique je vous remercie
monsieur le Président la parole est à
madame la Première ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
Président Chassaigne alors vous avez
raison de le dire monsieur le Président
la France est riche de ces outre-mer ce
sont des territoires d'avenir de
jeunesse ce sont des territoires à la
biodiversité inestimable ce sont des
territoires déterminants pour notre
souveraineté et pour notre économie mais
les outre-mer nous le savons également
ce sont des terres de défi le défi de la
vie chère auquel il nous faut répondre
le défi climatique qui menace certains
territoires le défi de l'emploi et de
l'attractivité le défi de la sécurité et
de la question migratoire et derrière ce
mot défi il y a des attentes bien sûr il
y a de la colère parfois il y a la
situation de la jeunesse
ultramarine qui attend légitimement des
réponses nous ne détournons pas le
regard de cette réalité avec le ministre
de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer Gérald
Darmanin le ministre chargés des
Outre-mer Jean-François carinco nous
sommes déterminés à y répondre pour
répondre à l'urgence sur le pouvoir
d'achat nous avons décidé cet été une
aide spécifique pour les outre-mer nous
avons revalorisé comme dans l'Hexagone
dans l'Hexagone des aides sociales et
les retraites nous travaillons à des
réponses structuelles alors en effet le
hudino de la vie chère vise à parvenir à
des accords de modération de coûts avec
les opérateurs privés pour les produits
de grande consommation des chartes ont
déjà été signés et d'autres sont en
cours de signature monsieur le Président
nous augmentons également les moyens
pour nos outre-mer dans le budget 2023
avec une augmentation de 10% du budget
nous investissons dans tous les domaines
notamment ceux qui permettent de lever
les difficultés du quotidien je pense à
la distribution de l'eau en Guadeloupe à
la lutte contre les Sargasses aux
Antilles aux questions du logement dans
l'ensemble de nos outre-mer nous invest
ils sont également pour accélérer la
transition écologique dans nos outre-mer
par exemple faire de la Réunion un
territoire pilote pour l'éolien flottant
nous renforçons les moyens pour la
sécurité et au moment de dire ces mots
je pense en particulier à la Guyane et à
Mayotte et monsieur le Président de
Chassaigne nous savons qui restent
beaucoup de chemin à parcourir vous
plaidez pour une nouvelle méthode c'est
bien ce sur quoi nous voulons travailler
c'était le sens de la réunion qui s'est
tenu le 7 septembre à l'Elysée autour du
président de la République suite à
l'appel des élus d'outre-mer le travail
a commencé dans un esprit d'ouverture
nous examinerons toutes les propositions
concrètes qui nous parviendrons et je
réunirai un conseil interministériel des
Outre-mer au prête au printemps prochain
qui suivra la mise en oeuvre des mesures
et surtout leurs résultats concret donc
vous le voyez sur tous ces sujets nous
souhaitons travailler deux concerts avec
les parlementaires avec les élus et je
sais pouvoir compter sur votre
mobilisation merci monsieur le président
je vous remercie madame la Première
ministre la parole est à Dominique
potier pour le groupe socialiste merci
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre le 27 mars 2017 la France
adopté une loi pionnière dans le monde
la loi devoir de vigilance qui levait le
voile juridique hypocrite qui séparait
les donneurs d'ordre des multinationales
de leur filiales et de leur
sous-traitants depuis cette date cette
idée n'a cessé de faire école dans
l'opinion publique déjà avec un cercle
parlementaire transpartisan désormais
pour le troisième mandat consécusif et
avec une résolution adoptée proposée par
le groupe socialiste et adopter le 20
janvier à l'unanimité dans cette
hémicycle cette loi a progressé
géographiquement en Europe avec
l'adoption par les Pays-Bas et
l'Allemagne en 2021 d'une loi
équivalente 5 autres pays suivent la
même voie et le 23 février de cette
année un projet de directive a été
proposé par la Commission européenne
madame la Première ministre vendredi
décembre dans quelques jours c'est le
conseil des chefs d'État et de
gouvernement qui prendra position sur la
proposition de la présidence tchèque en
vue d'adopter une directive qui sera
ensuite soumis au trilogue européen il
convient que cette loi soit la plus
forte possible ce n'est pas une loi
d'apparence c'est une loi pour les
enfants des mines de cobalt et des
champs de cacao c'est une loi pour les
peuples de l'Amazon et les paysans sont
terre c'est une loi pour les ouvriers
vigours en travail forcé dans les cadres
comme internement chinois cette loi
madame la Première ministre pour qu'elle
soit forte la France doit la porter
j'aimerais que vous puissiez clarifier
la position de la France dans ces
négociations autour de trois questions
le périmètre d'abord celui des
entreprises comprendra-t-il les filiales
au sens de la loi française les banques
sont-elles incluses dans ce dispositif
deuxième question la question de la
chaîne de production sera-t-elle portée
en amont et en aval à travers les
donneurs d'ordre cette loi
prendra-t-elle en compte les préjudices
écologiques au sens du préjudice du 1947
enfin la responsabilité civile
sera-t-elle au cœur de ce dispositif
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
madame la Première ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Dominique potier
l'Europe est d'abord une communauté de
valeurs c'est ce qui en fait un projet
politique et pas seulement économique et
cela doit se refléter pleinement dans
les règles que nous établissons au sein
de notre marché intérieur ou dans nos
relations commerciales avec le reste du
monde alors les exigences en matière
sociale en matière environnementale et
bien sûr aussi concernant les droits
humains doivent être au cœur des
législations que nous adoptons au sein
de l'Union on ne transige pas sur les
droits et les valeurs c'est cette
approche qui est au fondement de la
proposition de directives sur le devoir
de vigilance des entreprises en matière
de durabilité que la Commission a
proposé fin février et qui est en cours
de négociation
c'est pourquoi je le dis sans détour
nous sommes en faveur de cette directive
nous soutenons ce texte parce qu'il
favorise un comportement durable et
responsable des entreprises tout au long
de leur chaîne de valeur mondiale ces
règles apporteront de la sécurité
juridique aux entreprises et garantiront
une plus grande transparence pour les
consommateurs et les investisseurs nous
soutenons ce texte également parce qu'il
porte au niveau européen le combat que
nous avons d'abord mené au plan national
monsieur le député Dominique potier vous
le savez mieux que quiconque car vous
êtes à l'origine de la loi sur le devoir
de vigilance qui porte votre nom et dont
notre pays c'est de T en mars 2017 grâce
à vous la France a pu être pionnière en
la matière car aujourd'hui seuls trois
États membres ont déjà introduit des
règles nationales sur le devoir de
vigilance et si certaines entreprises
ont également pris des initiatives il
faut maintenant agir à plus grande
échelle celle de l'Union européenne sous
présidence française d'abord nous avons
fait de ce texte une de nos priorités
mon gouvernement reste aujourd'hui
pleinement mobilisé en vue d'obtenir le
meilleur des textes possible alors soyez
assurés monsieur le député que nous
travaillons sans relâche afin de
parvenir à un texte ambitieux un texte
ambitieux c'est un texte qui ne
transdige pas avec les valeurs sociales
environnementales et humaine un texte
ambitieux c'est un texte efficace qui
pose des règles claires un texte
ambitieux c'est un texte protecteur qui
prend en compte les risques de
concurrence déloyale de la part des
acteurs qui ne seraient pas soumis au
même règle c'est pourquoi fort de notre
expérience nous plaidons pour un cadre
de vigilance opérationnelle les
discussions menées au sein de cette
Assemblée avait permis de trouver cet
équilibre pour notre législation
nationale nous pouvons aller plus loin
en prévoyant des mesures de vigilance à
la fois plus précises et plus exigeante
en effet les grandes entreprises ont de
vis-à-vis de leur filiales fournisseurs
et sous-traitants elle doit utiliser
cette influence y compris sur leur
partenaire à l'étranger afin de
contribuer au respect des droits de
l'homme et à la protection de
l'environnement cette ambition doit être
la même dans tous les secteurs
d'activités concernés sans traitement
spécifique nous sommes évidemment très
attentifs à ce que le futur texte ne se
traduise pas par une baisse des
obligations de vigilance dans notre pays
et je compte sur vous monsieur le député
pour sensibiliser vos collègues
européens en faveur d'un système
pleinement équilibré notamment sur la
prise en compte des groupes
d'entreprises mesdames et messieurs les
députés ce sont ces principes que nous
portons dans les négociations en cours
elles se sont accélérées ces dernières
semaines nous espérons qu'il sera
possible de parvenir à un accord lors du
Conseil Compétitivité jeudi prochain le
travail continuera au Parlement européen
nous espérons une adoption de ce texte
majeur en 2023 en tout cas avant la fin
de la législature soyez certains que
nous sommes déterminer et mobilisé
je vous remercie madame la Première
ministre la parole est à Madame Clara
chassagnol pour vous prenez sens
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de la
transformation et de la fonction
publique monsieur le ministre mercredi
dernier vous avez présenté une nouvelle
grande étape de la réforme de la haute
fonction publique pour ces femmes et ses
hommes qui conduisent avec rigueur
dévouement parfois imagination la mise
en oeuvre des réponses aux
problématiques concrètes qui se posent à
nos concitoyens nous devons beaucoup à
notre haute fonction publique et aux
grandes écoles qui mènent elle a bâti
pour partie ce que nous sommes un État
fort et résilient pour affronter les
chocs face à des crises nouvelles et
multiples sanitaires géopolitiques et
climatiques ces qualités ne doivent pas
masquer le constat d'un effacement de
l'esprit méritocratique sans c'est la
caractériser par manque de diversité
dans les recrutements et un manque
d'agilité pour adapter les parcours de
vie et les carrières je voudrais à ce
propos saluer les transformations déjà
initiées dans le précédent mandat avec
la suppression de l'ENA avec la création
de la Délégation interministérielle à
l'encadrement supérieur de l'État qui a
doté la haute administration d'un
véritable service de de gestion des
ressources humaines et la création des
prépa talents qui méritent d'être mieux
connus car elles permettent aux élèves
de préparer les concours avec une bourse
de 4000 euros vous avez tracé monsieur
le ministre de nouvelles ambitions avec
la suppression du classement de sortie
de l'INSP davantage de mobilité de
reconnaissance des compétences
pourriez-vous nous préciser comment vous
comptez déployer ces transformations et
surtout faire savoir aux jeunes en
formation que ces carrières sont
passionnantes qu'elles sont valorisées
pour qu'il s'engagent dans cette voie
pour que l'on bénéficie dans nos
administrations de toutes les
compétences de la diversité sociale et
professionnelle des profils qui peuvent
y avoir accès contre les déterminismes
au profit de l'excellence et de la
méritocratie républicaine je vous
remercie je vous remercie mes chers
collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Stanislas Guerini ministre de la
transformation et de la fonction
publique merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée Clara chassagnol merci de
m'interroger sur cette nouvelle étape
déterminante de la réforme de la haute
fonction publique qui vient parachever
l'ambition que le Président de la
République avait émises dans le dernier
quinquennat
deux présidents de la République avant
lui François Hollande et Nicolas Sarkozy
avait émis la volonté de supprimer le
classement de sortie de l'ENA aucun des
deux n'avait plus aller au bout de cette
volonté et mesdames messieurs les
députés c'est cette majorité c'est ce
gouvernement sous l'autorité d'Elisabeth
borde c'est ce président de la
République qui sera allé au bout de
cette ambition et qui aura supprimé le
classement de sortie de l'ISP mesdames
et messieurs les députés comment
expliquer qu'un classement obtenu à 25
ans venez sceller une carrière entière
dans l'administration quand on est
engagé dans la lutte contre toutes les
formes de déterminés vous l'avez dit
madame la députée alors je crois que
tous les bancs de cette hémicycle
devraient soutenir cette réforme et en
l'occurrence cette réforme c'est une
réforme d'ambition pour institut
national de service public parce qu'elle
va permettre aux élèves de se concentrer
non pas sur l'optimisation d'un
classement de sortie mais de se préparer
à une carrière dans la haute
administration dans une logique de
professionnalisation c'est une réforme
d'ambition dont un autre élément et
l'harmonisation de tous les systèmes de
rémunération des administrateurs de
l'État autour de deux idées simples à la
députés l'attractivité et la récompense
de l'engagement assume de porter une
réforme qui vient porter à 30% la part
de rémunération variable pour les hauts
fonctionnaires de l'État je voudrais
conclure sur un dernier point cette
réforme ce n'est pas une réforme que
pour la haute fonction publique quand on
parle de diversité de mobilité des
carrières de gestion par les compétences
en réalité on porte bien une ambition
pour l'ensemble de la fonction publique
et pour l'égalité des chances dans notre
pays
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Benjamin sainte
huile pour le groupe Eliot
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse aux ministres de l'Agriculture
Marc féno monsieur le ministre cet
après-midi je souhaite vous parler de
l'inquiétude des agriculteurs qui ont
choisi de se lancer dans la production
bio et pour se faire je veux préciser
mon propos sur la question de la
production laitière je viens d'un
territoire la cendre ravennois ou plus
de 100 exploitations on fait le choix de
se convertir en bio ce qui représente
pour les hauts de France 80% de la
production de sort le château à semeries
d'Anor à winnerie à wineries jusqu'à
Dompierre-sur-Helpe la Sambre Avesnois
est mobilisée et a montré l'exemple en
2022 cela a été dit dans une question
précédente nous avons dû faire face tous
ensemble à la question de l'inflation
qui touche inévitablement les produits
bio qui font qui fait qu'aujourd'hui ces
produits ne sont évidemment pas ceux qui
sont regardés les premiers par les gens
qui sont attentifs à leur pouvoir
d'achat deuxième sujet particulièrement
impactant la question de la sécheresse
qui impacte nos agriculteurs et sur les
questions d'aide pour les herbes qui
relativement fragile du coup la question
que revie qui revient systématiquement
dans mes discussions avec les
agriculteurs de mon territoire c'est que
devons-nous faire nous produisons 1000
litres nous le vendons en moyenne 450
euros c'est revendu en grande
distribution
1310 euros la question que je vous pose
du coup monsieur le ministre allait
simple l'État et vous l'avez rappelé
dans une question précédente à
accompagner largement la conversion vers
le bio pour atteindre les objectifs
européens le territoire que je
représente fait partie des meilleurs
élèves de France les agriculteurs que je
croise aujourd'hui ils me disent
monsieur le ministre nous repartons dans
le conventionnel nous ne gagnions pas
notre vie nous allons faire marche
arrière pas question est simple
qu'allez-vous faire pour répondre à
cette urgence à des agriculteurs qui
souffrent qui ont été exemplaires dans
le choix de la conversion et qui ont le
sentiment à ce stade d'être abandonné
par le gouvernement je vous remercie
je vous remercie la ministre est à
Monsieur Marc penaud ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député 5 huile vous avez
très bien décrit la situation en
particulier des éleveurs laitier bio qui
souffrent de plusieurs conjonctures la
première c'était effectivement les
effets du dégradation de la consommation
de produits bio et c'est en particulier
vrai sur le lait plus que sur d'autres
secteurs du bio le deuxième élément
c'est le sujet de la hausse des charges
qui vient faire comme un effet ciseaux
et donc l'avenir qui se pose et le
risque pour un certain nombre de d'entre
eux de se lancer si je peux dire dans la
déconversion qui serait la pire des
choses parce qu'une fois qu'on est des
convertis évidemment en bio on ne refait
pas le chemin inverse quand on sait les
efforts qu'il faut parfois produire
d'abord agir sur l'urgence d'abord ce
que nous avons fait plan d'aide à
l'alimentation animale qui a été
déployée à partir du printemps près de
400 millions d'euros qui a concerné
d'autres filières d'élevage plus que le
bovin est en particulier mais quand même
qui a permis d'apporter une première
réponse deuxième réponse c'est les plans
d'allègement des charges que nous
déployons actuellement il y a près de un
quart des AG français qui se sont
manifestés qui manifesté leur intérêt
pour l'enlègement des charges ça
permettra de réduire la charge dans les
exploitations et d'améliorer la
trésorerie troisième élément les
calamité agricoles on a sous l'autorité
de la première ministre décidé de faire
en sorte qu'on puisse accélérer le
processus et que pour les régions qui
sont les plus touchés en termes de
sécheresse on puisse déployer les
calamités sécheresse dès le mois de
novembre les premiers versements ont eu
lieu au début de la semaine jusqu'au
évidemment pour les autres départements
qui rentreront au printemps mais en tout
cas on a voulu accélérer ses processus
souvent il y a un problème de trésorerie
puis quatrième élément là on est plus
sur le structurel c'est de regarder avec
d'abord la grande distribution on y
travaille avec Olivia Grégoire et Roland
Lescure à faire en sorte qu'on
revalorise le pré du lait des efforts
ont déjà été faits mais pas assez sur le
bio et donc il faut continuer et
quatrième élément c'est travailler plus
structurellement pour faire en sorte
qu'on relance la consommation on n'a pas
besoin d'un choc d'offre on a besoin
d'un choc de demande sur ces produits là
et donc c'est le travail que nous devons
mener avec les agriculteurs et les
producteurs laitiers en leur disant
qu'il faut qu'on essaie de passer le cap
qui est là pour retrouver la tendance
lourde qui était celle d'une
augmentation de la consommation
formation produit bio je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre monsieur
sainte-huile
merci Monsieur ministre je vous invite
donc à venir travailler avec les
agriculteurs de notre territoire sur ce
sujet majeur merci beaucoup je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Frédéric Falcon pour le groupe RN
rassemblement national
madame la présidente madame la ministre
la transition énergétique j'aimerais
rappeler dans cette émission que nos
très bonne nouvelle la France est
championne en Europe pour son
électricité des carbonée avec 50 g de
CO2 par kilowattheure notre pays est un
exemple en Europe face à l'Allemagne qui
émet 8 fois plus avec 400 à 500 g de CO2
par kilowattheure avec un triste record
d'éoliennes et de centrales à charbon
malgré cela vous souhaitez suivre
l'échec allemand en déposant nos lois
d'exception pour accélérer
l'installation d'éoliennes que vous
voulez multiplier au large des côtes
françaises notamment chez moi dans
l'Aude et les Pyrénées-Orientales à
Gruissan pour la nouvelle et le cas de
Barcarès et on se demande bien comment
l'installation d'éoliennes résoudrait à
notre crise énergétique car selon les
chiffres du ministère de l'écologie elle
ne produit que elle ne produit que 1,6%
de notre énergie primaire consommée en
France et 80 éoliennes que vous venez
d'inaugurer au large de Saint-Nazaire et
qui sont un énorme scandale de
produiront que 8% de la production de la
seule centrale nucléaire de Bugey pour
compenser cette centrale installée sur
un kilomètre au carré il faudrait
installer en mer 13 fois plus
d'éoliennes soit 1000 sur 1000 km2
et on ne peut être kefaré de découvrir
l'existence du lobby industriel éolien
lofat l'Office Franco-Allemand pour la
transition énergétique ce lobby qui a
comme membre les principaux
représentants de la filière éolienne
allemande à son siège à Berlin au
ministère de l'Industrie et pour adresse
en France les bureaux de la direction
générale de l'énergie et du climat
c'est-à-dire l'institution chargée en
France de notre politique énergétique
hébergée dans votre ministère oui mes
chers collègues un lobby des éoliennes
est abrité dans les locaux de
l'institution chargée de la politique
énergétique de la France et la même
comme membre l'organisation
anti-nucléaire Greenpeace madame la
ministre quelles sont les actions que
vous allez mettre en oeuvre pour
expulser de votre ministère un organisme
de lobbying qu'il n'y a pas sa place et
quelles actions allez vous mettre en
oeuvre pour lutter contre l'infiltration
de nos institutions par le lobby
anti-nucléaire et pro-olienne qui nous
mène dans une voie contraire aux
intérêts supérieurs de la France je vous
remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Agnès panière une ministre de la
transition énergétique merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Falcon
d'abord je vais préciser une chose la
loi que nous portons en ce moment pour
l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables elle porte sur l'ensemble
des énergies renouvelables elle porte
sur la géothermie elle porte sur le
biogaz elle porte sur le photovolotaïque
électrique et thermique il porte
effectivement aussi sur les éoliennes
comme elle porte sur la biomasse la
deuxième chose que je veux vous indiquer
c'est contrairement à ce que vous le
dites aujourd'hui notre énergie est au
2/3 fossiles et le nucléaire ne pèse que
20% de notre consommation finale
d'énergie c'est une réalité et la
deuxième réalité mais vous l'avez
évidemment en tête c'est que dans le
mouvement de relance des énergies
nucléaires que nous avons entamé avec ce
gouvernement et cette majorité ce
mouvement va prendre au minimum 15 ans
pour livrer son premier réacteur
européen alors que faisons-nous entre
deux que faisons-nous entre 2022 et 2035
dans un contexte où les Français vous
l'avez très bien dit tout à l'heure dans
votre groupe souffre de payer très cher
les énergies renouvelables Serges les
énergies fossiles au plan international
dans un contexte sous les entreprises
souffrent de pertes de compétitivité
nous nous avons choisi la voie de
l'action la voix de l'action c'est
d'accélérer sur les énergies
renouvelables c'est l'Agence
internationale d'énergie qui le dit
c'est le GIEC qui le dit parce que nous
avons une responsabilité
environnementale et nous avons une
responsabilité devant les Français de
sécuriser le déploiement de nouvelles
énergies sur notre territoire bas
carbone pas cher et accessible à tous
je vous remercie madame la ministre
monsieur Falcon et madame la ministre
vous n'avez pas répondu à la place de ce
lobby dans votre ministère vous engagez
pourtant votre responsabilité morale
devant la représentation nationale mais
il y a pas de surprise je crois que le
macronisme c'est l'art de la trahison
finalement merci
le rassemblement national c'est de
mauvaises solutions à devrais problèmes
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Anne-Cécile
violan pour le groupe horizon
chers collègues Madame le Ministre
Firmin le Bodo
tout comme par la médecine de travail ou
la médecine de ville de plus les
conséquences sur la santé des Français
sont majeures il est indispensable de
mieux le prendre en compte en
développement l'accès au lieu d'écoute
le Parlement a voté en 2022 une loi
visant à la création d'une plateforme de
référencement et de prise en charge des
maladies chroniques du covid cependant
madame la ministre il est urgent pour
des millions de qu'on ne compatriotes
d'accélérer la concertation et la
parution des décrets d'application
de plus alors que de nombreuses revues
scientifiques sont parues depuis deux
ans la recherche française manque
cruellement d'investissement notamment
pour entamer des essais thérapeutiques
demandés par des patients souffrant de
covid long ce sont près de 2 millions de
Français dans l'incapacité désormais de
poursuivre leur activité professionnelle
ainsi madame la ministre quelle réponse
pouvons-nous faire à ces millions de
Français une réponse qui soit à la
hauteur de leur souffrance leurs besoins
et leurs moyens merci beaucoup la parole
est à Madame Bodo ministre chargé de
l'organisation territoriale et des
professions de santé madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée Anne-Cécile
violence deux ans et demi après le début
de la crise sanitaire le parcours du
combattant n'en finit pas pour les
malades du covidon c'est bien pour cela
que ce sujet est un enjeu majeur pour le
ministère la réponse à cette
problématique reconnue comme vous l'avez
signalé comme une réalité clinique le
Docteur Dominique Martin a été confirmé
dans sa mission avec l'appui de la CNAM
et de toutes les administrations du
ministère fortement mobilisées sur ce
sujet six mois après la parution de la
feuille de route nous voulons avancer
vite nous réunirons dans la troisième
dans la première quinzaine de décembre
l'ensemble des parties prenantes
concernées pour un point d'étape ce qui
nous permettra d'aborder l'ensemble des
organisations territoriales mises en
place dans toutes les régions pour la
prise en charge et l'accompagnement des
malades du covid long mais aussi la
plateforme de référence et de prise en
charge des malades chroniques de la
covid prévues par la loi du 24 janvier
2022 sujet qui figure également dans la
lettre de mission néanmoins nous pouvons
aussi dire que des actions sont mises en
oeuvre et il faut peut-être les faire
savoir la CNAM a renforcé la mise à
disposition d'information sur la covidon
avec un espace dédié sur son site qui
regroupe tous les éléments utiles aux
patients prise en charge éléments
médicaux administratifs LD maladies
professionnelles offre de services de
l'assurance maladie les cellules d'appui
et de coordination post covid ont été
généralisées dans les territoires
l'information des médecins a été
renforcée mailing a dispiliation des
professionnels de santé sur les
ressources à leur disposition un outil
un outil aussi été développé par la CNAM
et l'association Tous partenaires covid
afin de faciliter le travail du médecin
traitant en recueillant les données
médicales du patient de manière
structurée un travail également été
entrepris avec le collège des masseurs
kinésithérapeutes pour réaliser des
vidéos de formation sur la prise en
charge des covidons ces vidéos ont été
mises en cet été les choses avancent les
malades ne sont plus laissées sans
réponse mais leur nombre et la diversité
des formes dont il souffre doivent nous
conduire à accentuer encore la
mobilisation de tout le système de santé
je vous remercie je vous remercie madame
la ministre la parole est à Monsieur
dinos ignorer pour le groupe les
républicains
ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre madame la Première
ministre jeudi dernier dans cette
hémicycle votre majorité minoritaire a
bloqué le début le débat sur la
réintégration des soignants non vaccinés
comme contre le covid-19 ce débat était
pourtant important et attendu par des
dizaines de milliers de nos compatriotes
soignants pompiers membres de leur
famille et patients ce débat est
d'autant plus légitime que la France est
l'un des tous premiers derniers pays en
Europe en avoir toujours pas réintégré
les soignants non vaccinés même la Grèce
va les réintégrer avant le 1er janvier
2023 la suspension de nos personnels de
santé devaient être temporaires pourtant
vous vous y opposez toujours alors que
nous vous proposions un protocole de
protection renforcée
près de 3000 infirmiers et aide-soignant
des centaines de médecins pharmaciens
orthophonistes kiné sont suspendus
depuis plus d'un an sans salaire ni
indemnisation de chômage et pendant ce
temps-là les hôpitaux font face à un
manque criant de soignants des enfants
se retrouvent sans suivi les
établissements médico-sociaux font
également face à des difficultés
majeures du fait d'un masque d'un manque
d'effectifs cela accentue la quantité de
travail des soignants présents et cela
affaiblit la qualité de la prise en
charge et des soins prodigués madame la
Première ministre les députés
républicains n'acceptent pas la mise au
banc d'une partie de nos soignants au
moment où on a le plus besoin de c'est
pourquoi nous vous demandons de
réintégrer son délai tous les soignants
que nous avons applaudis durant des mois
à 20 heures
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame maniabolo
ministre délégué chargé de
l'organisation territoriale et de la des
professions de santé madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député je tiens
d'abord à rappeler l'importance
l'importance essentielle de la
vaccination c'est grâce à elle que nous
avons pu retrouver une vie normale et
mieux protégée les plus fragiles d'entre
nous je rappelle que les campagnes
hivernales devaient de vaccination
contre la grippe et la covid ont débuté
j'invite tous nos concitoyens les plus
fragiles et ceux qui les entourent à se
vacciner contre ces deux maladies et
j'espère madame et messieurs les députés
que vous pourrez être en relais dans vos
circonscriptions de ce message la
vaccination protège notamment contre les
formes graves de ces deux virus je
rappelle que le principe de l'obligation
vaccinale a été votée par le Parlement
dans le cadre de la loi du 5 août 2021
relative à la gestion de la crise
sanitaire ce principe a été validé par
le Conseil constitutionnel je rappelle
également que nos professionnels de
santé pour la très grande majorité
d'entre eux sont les premiers à nous
dire être totalement opposé à la
perspective d'un retour de leur
collègues qui n'ont pas joué le jeu de
la vaccination et ce alors qu'ils sont
les premières victimes du monde de
personnel dans nos établissements de
santé c'est un principe éthique
essentiel et un devoir vis-à-vis des
personnes les plus vulnérables le
gouvernement est bien sûr
particulièrement attentif à la situation
avec une attalion particulière pour les
autres mères néanmoins plus encore sur
des territoires insulaires qu'ailleurs
la vaccination des professionnels de
santé protègent le système de santé est
garanti un accès aux soins pour tous
nous n'irons pas à l'encontre des
autorités scientifiques nous avons saisi
la semaine dernière conformément à notre
engagement la Haute Autorité de Santé
sur la révision de l'ensemble des
recommandations vaccinales des
professionnels exerçant dans le secteur
sanitaire et médico-social la Haute
Autorité se prononcera donc sur la
réactualisation des recommandations
vaccinales pour les professionnels de
santé en prenant en compte l'obligation
vaccinale contre la covid vous faisiez
allusion au protocoles mises en place
dans la PPL Fiat je vous rappelle que
votre groupe a dit que ce protocole
était inopérant dans la bouche de Madame
Josiane Corneloup je vous remercie
Monsieur signeri Madame labigny nous
vous demandons de respecter tous ceux
vacciner ou non qui démarche 2020 ont
soigné tous les patients alors que le
gouvernement votre gouvernement les
privés de masques et de blues elle et il
mérite la reconnaissance de la Nation
merci beaucoup
la parole est à Madame Christine arrier
pour le groupe écologiste
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre délégué chargé des
transports qui n'est pas là
nous n'avons plus d'autres choix que des
réponses rapides et coordonnées aux
différentes crises et chocs auxquelles
nous ne faisons face ainsi la question
des mobilités devient un enjeu de plus
en plus stratégique en particulier pour
les populations les plus précaires à la
question du prix de l'énergie s'ajoute
la nécessité d'accompagner le
déploiement des zones affaiblissement
mobilité dans l'agglomération
toulousaine
75% des habitants sont en dehors de les
pères centre et aujourd'hui obligé
d'utiliser leur voiture car ils ne
disposent pas d'un transport en commun
adapté et efficace ce chiffre tombe à
32% pour l'hyper centre plus dense et
donc mieux loti le RER constitue donc
une réponse efficace à cet enjeu bien
que la SNCF ait travaillé depuis
longtemps sur le concept de service
express métropolitain le soutien
financier et concret de l'État tarde à
se manif pourtant certaines villes
écologistes leur métropole ce sont déjà
engagés dans ces projets de RER
Strasbourg Bordeaux bientôt Lyon ont
déjà avancé vers de premier choc d'offre
pour ces motifs et sur la base des
constats faits dans le cadre du rapport
spécial transport le groupe écologiste a
déposé un amendement au projet de loi de
finances en faveur notamment du
financement des RER métropolitains à
m'en demande numéro 912 rejeté en
commission des finances et non discuter
en séance suite au recours du 49-3
le président de la République semble
soudain découvrir l'importance et
l'intérêt des services express
métropolitain nous le félicitons dès
lors est-ce à dire monsieur le ministre
qu'a défaut d'avoir fait en première
lecture le gouvernement va s'engager
dans un grand plan étatique de
régénération de monnaie du réseau
ferroviaire lors choix 1 de la Solo
anglais lecture du projet de là où là de
finances de 2023 ou soit 2 dans le cadre
d'un projet de loi de finance rectifié
merci beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Christophe de la transition écologique
et de la cohésion des territoires madame
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la député à Rigi
je n'ai aucun doute sur le fait que
Clément beau n'aurait adoré vous
répondre cet après-midi vous savez qu'il
est en train d'inaugurer le Technicentre
du Loiret et donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai le plaisir moi de pouvoir
vous répondre ici même dans cette
émission le soir vous avez appelé de vos
vœux un abonnement fort pour les
dépenses en matière d'infrastructure
ferroviaire je vous ai répondu que nous
attendions le rapport du coi et que nous
ferions ensuite en sorte de présenter un
plan cohérent rattaché à la
planification écologique et dont les RER
métropolitains seraient le socle je
m'aperçois que manifestement vous
préférez le silence quand vous posez la
question et le brouet quand j'essaye de
vous répondre avec pourtant la même
clarté et la même volonté vous avez
félicité le président de la République
je pense que c'est félicitations lui
iront droites au cœur je vous assure que
le gouvernement sous l'autorité
d'Elisabeth borne travaille à présenter
dans le cadre de la planification
écologique un projet qui soit cohérent
et qui soit global et qui ne traite pas
spécifiquement les RER métropolitains
mais bien l'accentuation des
investissements en termes de
régénération et de petites lignes le
financement de la généralisation des CCR
à un horizon 2040 le financement de
l'ERTMS à un horizon raisonnable sur
plusieurs milliers de kilomètres qui
nous permettent d'avancer et ces
investissements ferroviaires nous
parlons de plusieurs dizaines de
milliards d'euros d'un plan qui
répondent à la fois aux attentes des
territoires que nous aurons l'occasion
de rencontrer au début de l'année mais
aussi plus largement à cette ambition de
décarbonation parce que c'est bien de ça
dont nous parlons améliorer
effectivement la vie de des Français qui
sont dans ces agglomérations et qui
n'ont pas de service de transport à la
hauteur mais faire en sorte de proposer
des alternatives à la voiture et en
particulier aux voitures polluantes
contenu des enjeux de qualité de l'air
qui sont dans les zones affaiblissement
vous aviez évoqué au début de votre
intervention
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Madame Farida Amrani pour
le groupe la France insoumise merci
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre délégué en charge
des transports alors où le président de
la République annonce des projets de RER
dans 10 métropoles françaises et que
Île-de-France mobilité s'apprête à
augmenter le prix du Pass Navigo à 90
euros par mois le service public
francilien n'a jamais été aussi dégradé
les conditions de transport sont
insupportables train supprimer train
surchargé train retardé pénurie de
conducteur matériel défectueux et j'en
passe chaque jour en Île-de-France sont
près de 10 millions de déplacements qui
sont impactés par cette
dysfonctionnement la faute à qui au
désengagement financiers de l'État et à
l'irresponsabilité de la région
Île-de-France du TER au RER des régions
en métropole le service public est bradé
depuis plusieurs années
pas un jour pas un jour sans incident
sur la ligne du RER D empruntée par des
milliers d'habitants de ma
circonscription et c'est pareil sur
l'ensemble du réseau le RER ce n'est pas
qu'à Paris a dit le président Macron
mais pour le moment c'est plutôt bloqué
à la gare
il est temps de garantir un service
public digne de ce nom un service public
qui répond aux attentes et aux enjeux
climatiques et économiques de notre pays
plutôt que de vous renvoyer la balle
avec Madame Pécresse espérons que vous
réussirez au moins à convaincre votre
collègue en charge des comptes publics
de financer les annonces du président
pour rappel plus de 3 milliards d'euros
en faveur du transport ont été supprimés
par 49,3 dans le cadre du PLF monsieur
le ministre comment comptez-vous agir
pour que les transports soient enfin à
la hauteur des besoins quand monsieur
Beaune qui n'est pas là aura autant
d'ambition pour cette pour nos
transports publics que pour sa carrière
merci
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Amrani d'abord soyons humbles notre
réseau nécessite effectivement des
surplus de crédit en régénération mais
l'humilité elle vaut sur tous les bancs
parce que c'est pas le fruit de quelques
mois de sous-investissement c'est au
début des années 80 que les crédits que
nous avons commencé à consacrer à la
régénération du réseau
non on cessé d'être à la hauteur de
l'entretien de nos 29000 km de réseau le
choix de développer des LGV et de les
financer en minorant les crédits
d'entretien nous a amenés à la situation
et le gouvernement dont nous sommes les
continuateurs
ah au cours du dernier quinquennat
augmenter les crédits à la régénération
et pour le budget de l'année 2023 c'est
6,3 milliards d'euros qui sont consacrés
au ferroviaire c'est bien plus que la
moyenne de la décennie précédente et ça
marque les investissements
complémentaires comme nous avez fait
vous plaidez ici cet après-midi pour
qu'on présente un plan ferroviaire
ambitieux je viens de répondre déjà deux
fois à cette question en vous disant que
c'est dans le cadre de la planification
écologique mais vous verrez que le
moment venu vous trouverez des choses à
dire parce que la vérité c'est que vous
ne supportez pas que d'autres mettent en
oeuvre la planification écologique que
vous dont vous aimeriez avoir dont vous
aimeriez avoir le monopole alors sur les
questions du RER oui avec nextéo avec
les investissements qu'ils ont fait sur
le RER B sur le RD il y a des sujets sur
lesquels nous avançons mais là aussi
vous préférez pointer la galère
entretenir les dispositifs renvoyez la
balle et ne pas prendre vos
responsabilités en continuant sur un
sujet comme celui-là à être dans
l'incantation plutôt que l'action
l'action c'est le bloc de bâtissons
l'action c'est les dizaines de milliards
d'euros qui vous seront bientôt
présentés c'est la planification
écologique qui est portée mais ça
évidemment pour ne pas gêner votre fonds
de commerce vous voulez rester dans
l'outrance et dans l'incantation
[Musique]
je vous remercie madame Amrani monsieur
le ministre je vous invite à emprunter à
mes côtés dès demain le RER et on en
reparlera ensemble avec un grand plaisir
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Luc Fuji pour le groupe
Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la souveraineté
industrielle la semaine dernière vous
avez qu'au président la Conférence
ministérielle européenne qui avait pour
principalement enjeu l'avenir de
l'écosystème spatial européen à cette
occasion l'Agence spatiale européenne a
annoncé la sélection de Sophie adenau au
sein de la nouvelle promotion
d'astronaute
elle sera elle sera la deuxième femme
astronaute française après Claudie
Haigneré c'est une fierté pour la France
sur le ministre le Parlement suit le pré
des questions spatiales notamment par
les travaux de lopex l'Office
parlementaire d'évaluation des choix
scientifiques et technologiques début
novembre nous avons auditionné à l'OPEX
les principaux acteurs du spatial
français le CNES les grands groupes
industriels Ariane Thalès et Airbus
ainsi que plusieurs startups qui à leur
échelle aide aussi la France à conserver
son statut de puissance spatiale
de ces riches échanges il ressort que
face à la concurrence américaine et
chinoise une Europe souveraine doit
conserver un accès autonome à l'espace
grâce au Centre spatial guyanais et à
une nouvelle génération de lanceur de
Ariane 6 ouvrira la voie cette
souveraineté un coup dont nous ne
pouvons pas faire l'économie
pour une Europe agit de souveraine il
lui faut disposer de sa propre
constellation de ministres satellites
pour assurer sa connectivité dans la vie
de tous les jours mais aussi pour les
applications de défense les dernières
annonces du commissaire européen Thierry
Breton sont rassurantes mais le
calendrier doit être précisé enfin face
à l'urgence climatique l'observation de
la Terre par satellite se révèle crucial
l'Europe doit être par exemple capable
de mesurer ses propres émissions de gaz
à effet de serre mais aussi celle des
autres pays pour assurer sa crédibilité
dans les négociations internationales
monsieur le ministre au vu de ses
nombreux enjeux pouvez-vous nous
présenter les décisions majeures prises
au niveau européen la semaine dernière
et nous indiquer à quelle hauteur se
situe l'ambition française pour répondre
à ces défis majeurs face aux différentes
crises que traverse le monde
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Roland Lescure Ministre chargé
le l'industrie merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Jean-Luc
fujith merci pour cette question sur un
sujet vous l'avez dit qu'il vous
mobilise depuis déjà de nombreuses
années au sein au sein de l'OPEX je
voudrais d'abord commencer par vous
l'avez fait mais je voudrais le faire à
nouveau saluer nos deux spationautes qui
ont été sélectionnés d'abord Arnaud pros
retenu pour la réserve et la semaine
dernière c'était la Semaine de
l'industrie que nous avions décidé de
mettre sur le thème de la place des
jeunes filles et des femmes dans
l'industrie française et je suis
particulièrement fier au nom du
gouvernement de féliciter Sophia no vous
l'avez dit qui sera 25 ans après Claudie
ignoré une spationaute française qui
j'espère elle aussi conquera l'espace
et qui vient de Bourgogne monsieur
riberotte on est très heureux vous
l'avez dit Bruno Le Maire avec Sylvie
Retailleau présidait la Conférence
ministérielle sur l'agence européenne
spatiale la semaine dernière et ça a été
l'occasion de renforcer et d'affirmer à
nouveau l'engagement de la France et de
l'Europe sur les programmes
européens spatiaux c'est un très bel
engagement collectif des États européens
qui nous conduit à voter ensemble un
budget d'investissement global de 17
milliards d'euros sur trois ans les
années 23 24 et 25 dont 3,7 milliards
d'euros je pense que c'était votre
question monsieur le député qui viendra
de la France en hausse de 10% de 20%
pardon par rapport à 2019 c'est
important évidemment de souligner et de
rappeler que la France reste le pays
premier contributeur en Europe
au programme européen spatial de l'ESSA
ce qui n'empêche pas évidemment la
France de continuer des développements
nationaux puisque au total ce sont 9
milliards d'euros qui sont consacrés au
secteur spatial dans les trois
prochaines années telles qu' annoncé par
madame la Première ministre deux
objectifs principaux pour ce programme
d'abord vous l'avez dit renforcer
l'autonomie européenne dans le secteur
spatial l'officement le financement
d'Ariane 6 mais aussi la préférence
européenne pour le lancement des
satellites européens c'est important et
deuxième point très important améliorer
la connaissance du changement climatique
à travers le financement de programme
d'observation merci Monsieur le Ministre
la séance des questions gouvernement est
terminée la séance est suspendue
[Applaudissements]